JOINT HEARING OF THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE
ON THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE TO ORDER TODAY'S
HEARING WILL FOCUS ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
LICENSING SPECIFICALLY ITS
RECENT AND PLANNED TECHNOLOGY
EFFORTS AND BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION PLANS CHIRLA
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US THIS
MORNING I. FOR THE- I WHEN I
WAS CARE AT THE ASSEMBLIES
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMITTEE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I ASKED THE
TEAM TO DO WAYS DO A SURVEY OF
ALL THE DISTRICT OFFICE SAYS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND TO ASK DISTRICT STAFF WHAT
ARE THE TOP ISSUES THAT
CONSTITUENTS COME TO YOU IF YOU
KNOW WHERE THE PLACES WHERE.
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNMENT ISN'T
DOING AS GOOD A JOB AS WE NEED
TO DO AND AS I'VE SHARED WITH
WITH THAT DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS ONE OF THE TOP
ISSUES THAT ARE DISTRICT OFFICE
GRAPPLE WITH OUR COMPLAINTS
ABOUT PROFESSIONAL LICENSING
AND THE PROCESS SO IT'S ONE OF
THE TOP CONSTITUENT ISSUES AND-
I CLEARLY ONE OF THE PLACES
WHERE WE CAN DO A BETTER JOB
MAKING GOVERNMENT. BETTER FOR
THE CALIFORNIANS WERE WE
REPRESENT SO THAT REALLY IS BIG
PICTURE THE GOAL OF TODAY'S
HERE ACT AND I TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO GET AN UPDATE ON DCA
LICENSING AND DC IS BUSINESS.
ERNEST XIN PLAN. FIVE MINUTES
FOR THE QUESTIONS I HAVE WOULD
RECALLS FOR THIS PROJECT.
WHAT'S THE TIMELINE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION WHAT'S THE
BUDGET. ARE WE ON TRACK AND
IMPORTANTLY WHAT IS BEING DONE
TO ENSURE THAT. LICENSING IS IN
A PAIN POINT FOR CONSTITUENTS.
IN PANEL ONE WILL HEAR AN
UPDATE FROM THE LA AND DCA
ABOUT PROFESSIONAL LICENSING
AND MODERNIZATION. IN PANEL TWO
WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS ON HOW DCA
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY. AND BOARDS IN
BUREAUS ARE WORKING TOGETHER TO
PLAN AND UPDATE THEIR
TECHNOLOGIES WE'RE ALSO GOING
TO GET AN UPDATE FROM TWO
BOARDS ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCE I
WHEN. A BREEZE USER FROM AN
EARLIER ITERATION OF DC ETS
TECHNOLOGY IMPLEMENTATION AND
ONE PLANNING TO TRANSITION TO A
NEW TECHNOLOGY SOON. TO ALL OF
OUR PANELISTS THANKS SO MUCH
FOR TAKING TIME OUT OF YOUR
BUSY SCHEDULES TO BE HERE AND
JOIN US TODAY LOOK FOR TO OUR
DISCUSSION. CHIRLA WOULD YOU
LIKE TO MAKE AN OPENING
STATEMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND GOOD MORNING TO EVERYONE
JUST WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
THE- MAN CHAIR FOR THE TYPE OF
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT WE WANT TO SEE. A FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND FOR AT
CONSUMERS ALIKE TO SO A VERY
MUCH LOOKING FOR TO THE
DIALOGUE AND CONVERSATION AND
EXCITED TO GET STARTED.
WONDERFUL WOULD ANYONE ELSE
LIKE TO MAKE AN OPENING
STATEMENT. OKAY GREAT LET'S GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED OPTIONAL
ONE IS AN UPDATE ON
PROFESSIONAL LICENSING AND
MODERNIZATION. ALL GOT A LETTER
PANELISTS COMING UP AND YOU CAN
INTRODUCE YOURSELF TO I. TWO
GOOD MORNING GEN GOT AND JUST
GIVE YOUR GIVE A QUICK INTRO.
HI CHRISTY WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE GOOD MORNING
I'M CHRIS SHELTON THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT THE
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
JASON BUT SHOWING THE CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
WELCOME I CAN'T TELL AND I
THINK YOU'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
GET US STARTED YES THANK YOU SO
MUCH CHAIRED MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME TODAY TO JUST
GIVE SOME BRIEF REMARKS.
SUMMARIZING THE DEPARTMENT AND
ALSO LAYING THE LAND A LITTLE
BAD ON THEIR I. T. PROJECTS I
THERE'S A HANDOUT THAT I
PREPARED YOU SHOULD HAVE COPIES
THE SERGEANTS ALSO HAVE EXTRA
COPIES AND IT'S AVAILABLE
ONLINE. FOR VIEWERS OF CAL
CHANNEL OR OTHER PLACES. AND SO
I'LL JUST START ON PAGE ONE
WITH A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND
ON THE DEPARTMENT. THAT'S THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
IS RESPONSE. FOR PROMOTING
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
SUPPORTING A FAIR AND
COMPETITIVE MARKET PLACE. IT'S
REALLY AN UMBRELLA DEPARTMENT
SO. IT HAS WITHIN IT ALMOST
FORTY BOARDS BUREAUS AND OTHER
PROGRAMS. THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE
FOR. THIS ACHIEVING THIS
MISSION. THROUGH THIS
DEPARTMENT THEY PERFORM TWO
MAIN ACTIVITIES THESE BOARDS
AND AEROSPACE A LICENSE SO THE
DEPARTMENT LICENSES ABOUT.
THREE MILLION PROFESSIONALS. IN
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES SO A RANGE
OF DIFFERENT FOLKS AT FROM
DOCTORS ACUPUNCTURISTS. YEP
FOLKS WHO DO COSMETOLOGY A
WHOLE RANGE OF FOLKS. AS WELL
AS A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
BUSINESSES SO PLACES LIKE AUTO
REPAIR FACILITIES AND OTHER
TYPES OF BUSINESSES. THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO CONDUCTS
ENFORCEMENT WHICH IS ANOTHER
CRITICAL ASPECTS SO FOR EXAMPLE
IF THERE ARE COMPLAINTS ABOUT.
THESE PROFESSIONALS THE
DEPARTMENT WILL INVESTIGATE
THOSE COMPLAINTS AND TAKE
ACTION. WHEN APPROPRIATE. SO
THAT TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET PROVIDES OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED AND THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS TO THE
DEPARTMENT AND SPORTS IN
BARROWS. THAT SUPPORTS OVER
THREE THOUSAND POSITIONS. THE
DEPARTMENT AND ITS ASSOCIATED
ENTITIES. AND BASICALLY THE
DEPARTMENT IS. ALMOST ENTIRELY
FUNDED BY THE FEE PAID BY THOSE
THAT IT LICENSES. WHAT'S REALLY
DOCTORS THE. COSMETOLOGIST THAT
THOSE WHO ARE PAYING OFF.
PERMIT AS WELL AS ITS IT
PROJECTS THAT WILL DISCUSS. SO
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE TWO WE
PROVIDE SOME BACKGROUND ON THE
HISTORY OF THE DEPARTMENT'S IT
PROJECTS SO HISTORICALLY THE
DEPARTMENT HAD A VARIETY OF
LEGACY IT SYSTEMS THAT WERE IN
PLACE AT THESE INDIVIDUAL PORTS
AND BUREAUS AND SO THEY ALL HAD
SORT OF. YOU KNOW THERE'S SOME
THAT WERE IN PLACE AT A VARIETY
OF THEM BUT THERE WERE A WHOLE
COULD HOST OF KIND OF HODGE
PODGE OF DIFFERENT SYSTEMS. AND
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
SYSTEMS THEY DIDN'T HAVE YOU
FOLKS COULDN'T PAY ONLINE THEY
WEREN'T YOU KNOW THEY DIDN'T
HAVE THE FUNCTIONALITY THAT WAS
A NEEDED BY THESE BOARDS IN
EUROS IN MANY CASES THERE WERE
SOME DATA ISSUES THEY WON'T
NECESSARILY VERY USER FRIENDLY
SO THERE REALLY WERE A NUMBER
OF CHALLENGES THAT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAD IDENTIFIED. AND
WANTED TO ADDRESS THROUGH AN I.
T. SYSTEM AND SEVEN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE THE
DEPARTMENT REALLY LOOPS
LAUNCHED AN EFFORT TO TY TO
UPGRADE ITS IT SYSTEMS FOR
THESE BOARDS IN PEROT'S THAT'S
THIS THERE ARE THAT SERVE
EFFORT WAS A BREEZE. IT WAS
PROPOSED TO BE NINE INTEGRATED
I. T. SOLUTION REALLY BRING THE
BOARDS AND ROSE UP TO KIND OF
THAT THE MODERN I. T. KIND OF
SOLUTIONS FOR LICENSING AND
ENFORCEMENT. IT WAS ORIGINALLY
PROPOSED TO BE COMPLETED IN
THREE FATE IS UP OR RELEASES
WITH. ROUGHLY HALF OF THE
BOARDS AND GROWS IN THAT THIRD
RELEASE. IT WAS SUPPOSED TO
HAVE A BUDGET OF TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS. AND IT WAS A
REALLY ENVISIONED TO BE
COMPLETED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN. I TOOK HER WAS
SELECTED AS THE VENDOR OUT TO
DO THE IMPLEMENTATION. AND THAT
HAPPENED IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. I SO THE FIRST RELEASE
OCCURRED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN AND UNFORTUNATELY
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES THAT EMERGED IN
THEIR MERCH PRETTY QUICKLY. SO
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES THEIR
PERFORMANCE PROBLEMS THAT MADE
IT DIFFICULT FOR SOME OF THESE
BOARDS INTERESTED TO THEIR
LICENSING ACTIVITIES. THERE
WERE DELAYS THERE ARE
SUBSTANTIAL COST INCREASES AND
THERE'S A STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT THAT OUTLINED A LOT OF
THESE CHALLENGES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT FACED. US A GIVEN
THESE CHALLENGES THE
ADMINISTRATION AND FROM THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN THAT IT INTENDED TO
CANCEL THE PROJECT. AFTER
RELEASE TO. AND A LOT OF THIS
WAS DUE TO INCREASED COSTS AS
WELL AS THESE OTHER ISSUES THAT
ACOSTA TOTALED. ABOUT NINETY
SIX MILLION JUST FOR THAT
RELEASED ONE INTO SO FOR ABOUT
HALF THE PROJECT AT THAT POINT.
I SO IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THE DEPARTMENT DID LAUNCH
RELEASE TO AN IN GENERAL I
THINK THE- RESPONSE WITH THAT
THAT WAS MORE SUCCESSFUL THAN
RELEASE ONE AND THAT THINGS
WENT PRETTY WELL THERE. BUT
THERE IS STILL A NEED REALLY TO
MEET THAT THE I. T. NEEDS OF
THESE REALLY THREE BOARDS IN
BUREAU SO ABOUT HALF OF THAT
BOARD OF YOURS IN THE
DEPARTMENT STILL DIDN'T HAVE AN
UPGRADED SYSTEM. SO THE
LEGISLATURE WAS INTERESTED IN
GETTING A PLAN FOR THAT. THAT
SORT OF ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN
FOR ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF
THESE ENTITIES AND IF YOU TURN
TO PAGE THREE. WE DISCUSS A
LITTLE BIT THAT PLAN SO
BASICALLY. I COULD DIRECTION OF
THE LEGISLATURE. IN. THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE DEPARTMENT
SUBMITTED A PLAN FOR ADDRESSING
THE NEEDS OF THESE ENTITIES AND
THIS WAS CALLED THE BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION PLAN. IT WAS
SUBSEQUENTLY UPDATED IN
DECEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN. AND THIS IS REALLY A
VERY DIFFERENT APPROACH FROM
WHAT WAS ORIGINALLY ENVISIONED
AND BREEZE DEGREES WAS GIVE ME
THIS ONE SYSTEM IS GOING TO.
KIND OF MEET THE NEEDS OF
EVERYONE. BUT I THINK IT WAS
SORT OF A LITTLE BIT OF A BUT I
TEND TO TRY TO HAVE THIS. SORT
OF. CATCH ALL. ONE SYSTEM FOR
EVERYONE THIS WAS THIS NEW
EFFORT IS BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION EFFORT IS REALLY
HAVE A DIFFERENT APPROACH. I
THINK IT RECOGNIZE THAT ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT BREEZE
ENCOUNTERED OR SUMMIT
CHALLENGES ENCOUNTERED WERE AS
A RESULT OF. A MAYBE AN
OVERSIMPLIFICATION OF AN IDEA
OF WHAT THESE ENTITY'S WOULD
NEED IN THAT. AND PRACTICE
ACTUALLY. THEY ARE VERY UNIQUE
AND THEY HAD FRENCH KINDS OF
BUSINESS NEEDS THAT REALLY
NEEDED TO BE EVALUATED AND-
MUCH MORE THOROUGH WAY. AND
THAT YOU KNOW MAYBE THEY WOULD
HAVE DIFFERENT ULTIMATE I IS IN
TERMS OF WHAT THE SOLUTION
WOULD BE FOR THEM SO MAYBE ONE
SYSTEM WOULDN'T BE. WOULDN'T BE
A SOLUTION FOR ALL OF THEM. SO
IF YOU HAVE THAT CONSISTENT
WITH THE FOCUS. BACK TO REVISED
PLAN AND FOCUS. THAT THIS UNDER
HIS ASIAN PLAN. VISION WARDS IN
BUREAUS NOT DOING ONE
IMPLEMENTATION ALTOGETHER BUT
REALLY MOVING MORE AT THEIR OWN
TIMELINE. ON THEIR LEVEL OF
READINESS AND ALSO POTENTIALLY
IMPLEMENTING DIFFERENT SYSTEMS
SO INSTEAD OF HAVING ONE PRE
SYSTEM THAT COVERS EVERYONE.
SOME OF THESE ENTITIES YOU
MIGHT BE ON DIFFERENT SYSTEMS
AND IN FACT WILL HAVE THAT.
FREE SYSTEM WHICH WILL COVER
RELEASED ONE INTO THE BEER CANS
CONTROL HAS A DIFFERENT SYSTEM.
AND IT WORKS ACTING BAD THE
RELEASE THREE ENTITIES TO HAVE
AT LEAST ONE OTHER SYSTEM SO
IT'LL BE. A FEW DIFFERENT
SYSTEMS IN PLACE THROUGHOUT THE
DEPARTMENT. SO THERE ARE REALLY
VERY LEVELS OF PROGRESS TO DATE
FOR THOSE RELEASED THREE BOARDS
IN YOUR THINKING GO HERE
PROBABLY MORE ABOUT THIS COMING
UP. BUT. SEVEN TO DATE HAVE
COMPLETED BUSINESS ACTIVITIES
AND THOSE ARE THINGS LIKE
ACTUALLY MAPPING WHAT THEIR
BUSINESS PROCESSES ARE
CURRENTLY AND WHAT THEY SHOULD
BE. AND FOR HAVE COMPLETED
THEIR ANALYSES OF PROJECT
ALTERNATIVES AND REALLY HAVE
PROPOSED A SORT OF KIND OF
SOLUTION THAT THEY WANT TO
UNDERTAKE AND THAT'S BASICALLY
PHASE TWO OF THE PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFECYCLE PROCESS
WHICH I THINK YOU'LL ALSO HEAR
ABOUT. SHORTLY. SO ALSO IT'S
DONE THE FIGURE ON PAGE FOR
THESE ENTITIES AS TO HAVE
DIFFERENT ESTIMATED COMPLETION
DATE SO THAT FIGURE SHOWS. ON
THEM THE DEPARTMENT'S MOST
RECENT ESTIMATES OF WHEN THESE
VARIOUS PORTS IN EUROS WILL
ACTUALLY BE FULLY TRANSITIONS
THEIR NEW SYSTEMS SEE SEE THAT
A NUMBER WILL BE. WILL BE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BUT THEY EXTEND ALL
THE WAY OUT TO TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE SO IT'LL BE SEVERAL YEARS
BEFORE REALLY THE WHOLE
DEPARTMENT HAS. UPGRADED IT
SYSTEMS. IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
FIVE WE JUST BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE
THE RECENT BUDGET ACTION SO IN
THE NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET.
THERE WERE AND SIX DIFFERENT
ENTITIES THAT RECEIVE BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS TO HELP THEM MOVE
FORWARD FORWARD WITH THEIR
PROJECTS RELATES TO THE EARLY
IMPLEMENTATION OF THEIR THEIR
PROJECTS. TO THESE ENTITIES ARE
REALLY A DIFFERENCE SERVE EARLY
RELATIVELY EARLY STAGES SOME OF
THEM ARE STILL DOING A BUSINESS
PROCESS EVALUATION SOME OF THEM
HAVE COMPLETED PHASE TWO. OF
THE STATE TO GET PROCESS. STAGE
TWO BUT THEY'RE ALL STILL
REFINING THE TOTAL COST
ESTIMATES OF SOME OF THEM HAVE
SOME PRELIMINARY COST ESTIMATES
BUT NOT THE TOTAL COST
ESTIMATES OF THIS FIVE POINT
FIVE MILLION. IS WHAT WAS
PROVIDED JUST FOR NINETEEN
TWENTY AND A ONE TIME BASIS BUT
THE FULL PROJECT COSTS AFTER
THESE ENTITIES HAVEN'T BEEN
FULLY ACCESS AT THIS POINT. I
SOME HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS EITHER NOW OR OR
AFTER THE MEETING SPEAKERS. OF
THIS I DON'T HAVE QUESTIONS AT
THIS POINT. YOU WILL HEAR FROM
THE OTHER SPEAKERS AND YOU NOT
FOR YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND THEN I
KNOW I'VE GOT A FEW MONTHS.
GREAT. GOOD MORNING I'M CHRIS
SCHULTZ THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT
THE DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS
I APPRECIATE THE OF TINA
HIGHLIGHT THE SOLID WORK I
THINK OUR TEAM IS DOING TO MOVE
DC PROGRAMS TO NEW IT SYSTEMS
THAT MEET THEIR BUSINESS NEEDS
WE ARE ALL AWARE OF THE
CHALLENGES FEAST IN ROLLING OUT
BREEZEDURING THE FIRST RELEASE
AYE YOUR PREDECESSORS HAD MANY
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS AND MY
PREDECESSOR SAT AT THIS TABLE
IN ANSWER TO A BUNCH OF
QUESTIONS. DCA IS A INTERESTING
DEPARTMENT WE HAVE IS HELL.
MENTION NEARLY FORTY BOARDS
BUREAUS COMMITTEES AND
COMMISSIONS. EACH PROGRAM IS
UNIQUE AND THEY ALSO HAVE
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
AUTONOMY FOR EXAMPLE THE TO
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS YOU'LL HEAR
FROM LATER WE HAVE A GOVERNOR
APPOINTED BOARD CAN OF THE
BOARD OF CHARACTER JAMMERS
MOSTLY APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR ONE SENATE ONE
ASSEMBLY APPOINTEE. THEY HIRE
THEIR OWN EXECUTIVE OFFICER THE
APPOINTEES SO DC AXES AN
UMBRELLA SOME OF THESE BOARDS
ARE BECAUSE I AUTONOMOUS AND SO
WE ACTED ACCORDING ROLE. BUT
DON'T ALWAYS DIRECT FOLKS LIKE
WE MIGHT IN A IN A DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENT THE FOLKS WHO RUN
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS. SO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THE
STRUCTURE THEIR SOME PROGRAMS
THAT CEMETERY FUNERAL BIER
WHERE THE DIRECTOR HIRES THAT
BUREAU CHIEF AND- THE BULL
CASES JUST ADVISER IT'S NOT A
GOVERNING. BOARD BUT IT'S A I'M
NOT GOING TO. HAVE DIFFERENT.
WITH THE BREEZE A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL SOLUTION DOESN'T WORK SO
WE'VE MOVED TO. EIGHTY BUSINESS
FOCUS PROCESS WHERE EACH
PROGRAM IS IN THE DRIVER'S SEAT
OF THEIR BUSINESS MODERNIZATION.
I WE THINK THAT THIS STRATEGIES
ALREADY DEMONSTRATING SUCCESS
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL IS
BEING INCUBATED AT THE TO
PUBLIC CONSUMER AFFAIRS THEY
HAD A HARD STATUTORY DEADLINE
FOR TILTING UP THEIR I. T.
SYSTEM. WE MET THAT GOAL THERE
IT SYSTEM WAS UP AND IT WORKS.
TURNING BACK TO THE SEVENTEEN
PROGRAMS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY IT WOULD BE NAIVE TO
PRESUME THERE MIGHT NOT BE
CHALLENGES WE MIGHT HAVE NOT
HAVE THIS SMALL DELAYS. BUT. IN
TALKING TO ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS BOTH THE DC
EIGHTEEN AND ALL THE BOYS AND
GIRLS I'M I'M VERY CONFIDENT
THAT WE'RE ON THE RIGHT PATH.
ON IT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT NOTE
THAT WE APPRECIATE OUR PARTNERS
ACT OUT DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THOSE TWO ENTITIES PROVIDE A
LOT OF OVERSIGHT CDT APPROVED
EACH OF THESE PROJECTS AT EVERY
STAGE GATE. AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ONLY PUTS THE MONEY
IN THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY TEN
BUDGET IF THEY THINK THAT WE'RE
ON THE RIGHT TRACK. SO THERE
ARE CONTROL AGENCIES LOOK AT
THIS BEFORE. BEFORE JUST UP IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. BEFORE
CLOSING I WANT TO BE REALLY
CLEAR THAT DC IS STRIVING FOR
AND NORMA'S TRANSPARENCY OUT
WITH THESE PROJECTS. IN
ADDITION TO THE ANNUAL REPORT
WE'VE PRODUCED TWICE ON THIS
PROJECT. AND THE OVERSIGHT THAT
WE'VE RECEIVED IN THE BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEES. AND THE LA HAS
ENOUGH TO WEIGH IN ON THE
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES. ONE
RECOMMIT TODAY TO MEETING WITH
LEGISLATORS AND COMMITTEE STAFF
AS FREQUENTLY AS YOU SEE FIT TO
PROVIDE. FREQUENT UPDATES ON
THE BUSINESS MODERNIZATION
PROJECT AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE KNOWS WHERE WE ARE
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY. THANKS
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME AND HAVE IT
ANSWERED QUESTIONS. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN MY NAME IS JASON
Và CHURNING ON THE CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER FOR DCA. IN
ORDER TO BE NOT BE DUPLICATIVE
I MIGHT JUMP INTO MY ROOM A
LITTLE BIT DEEPER AS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE HAVE ALREADY
STATED SOME FACTS REGARDING
BREEZE SO I'LL JUMP INTO IT.
IT'S WELL DOCUMENTED THE
CHALLENGES THAT BREEZE RELEASE
ONE FACED WHAT'S A LITTLE BIT
LESS TALKED ABOUT IS THE PIVOT
THAT DCA EXECUTED IN ORDER TO.
RIGHT RELEASED TO AND IMPLEMENT
THAT SMOOTHLY AND EVEN LESS.
WELL KNOWN IS THE ABILITY FOR
THE RELEASE ONE FOUR TWO DID
HAVE CHALLENGES EARLY ON TO
MORE SMOOTHLY APPLY THEIR THAT
BREEZE IMPLEMENTATION TO THEIR
BUSINESS. AND ULTIMATELY GET ON
BOARD AND RUN OPERATION
SMOOTHLY WITH BREEZE SEVERAL
LOTS OF LESSONS LEARNED FROM
THE BREEZE IMPLEMENTATION
HIGHLIGHT JUST A COUPLE OF THEM
NOW. WE LEARNED WE NEEDED A
GREATER FOCUS ON ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGE MANAGEMENT. WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE BUSINESS WAS
AN ACTIVE OWNER UNDERSTOOD THE
EXPECTATIONS AND PARTICIPATION
LEVELS AT ALL STAGES WE
LEARNED OF THE SYSTEM
REQUIREMENTS HAD TO DERIVE
PRIMARILY FROM THE BOARDS IN
BUREAUS THEMSELVES WILL NOT
OVER VALUING SIMILARITIES
BETWEEN THE BOARDS OR UNDER
VALUING DIFFERENCES. AND THE
RELATED TO ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGE MANAGEMENT WE LEARNED
THAT VERY TIMELY TRAINING FOR
STAFF WAS VERY HIGH ON OUR LIST
OF LESSONS LEARNED. THE LESSONS
OF THESE LESSONS LEARNED AS
WELL AS NEW STATE PROJECT
DIRECTOR AND PROJECT LEADERSHIP
LED TO OF A VASTLY IMPROVED
RELEASED TO. AND ALSO WITH THE
FOUNDATIONS OF OUR BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION PLAN. THE BEST
ILLUSTRATION I COULD PROVIDE
REGARDING THE POSITIVE EFFECTS
ON BREEZE TODAY ARE THE EVER
INCREASING ONLINE ADOPTION
RATES FOR THE FISCAL YEAR
EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE BOARD
OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES. I NEED
TO PER THEIR LICENSE RENEWAL
THROUGH THE PRE SYSTEM ONLINE.
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING HAD
99% BOARD OF OPTOMETRY AT 84%
BOARD OF VOCATIONAL NURSING AT
EIGHTY SIX AND RESPIRATORY CARE
BOARD HAD NINETY ONE PERCENT.
OF ALL OF THESE LICENSE
RENEWALS 9295% OF THEM WERE
DONE WITHOUT STAFF INTERVENTION.
SO WE THINK THAT'S A VERY GOOD
STAFF THAT CONTINUES TO GROW I
CONTINUES TO SHOW THE FOR THE
POSITIVE IMPACTS THE BREEZES
HAD. THE FOCUS OF OUR
DEPARTMENT IS MEETING ITS
CLIENTS AND CUSTOMERS WHERE
THEY ARE AT USING MOBILE AND
ONLINE DEVICES TO CONDUCT THEIR
EVERYDAY ACTIVITIES AND SINCE
THE BREEZE STABILIZATION OF
BIRD BREEZE RELEASED TO IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE'VE EVOLVED
THIS BUSINESS MODERNIZATION
METHODOLOGY. AND HOW THE
REMAINING SEVENTEEN BOARDS
WOULD PLAN DESIGN AND IMPLEMENT
THEIR INDIVIDUAL BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION MODERNIZATION
INITIATIVES. THE NAME BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION IS NOT BY CHANCE
WE DO NOT CALL IT TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION OR EVEN AN IT
PROJECT AT ALL WHILE THAT MIGHT
SOUND COUNTERINTUITIVE WHAT I
MEAN IS THAT WE LOOK TO IMPROVE
BUSINESS PROCESSES AND SERVICE
DELIVERY. BY HAVING OUR BOARD
IN BUREAU SAID THE PROJECT
OWNERS DRIVE DIRECT PARTICIPATE
AND EXECUTE INITIATIVES ARE
PROGRAMS BETTER UNDERSTAND
THEIR BUSINESS PROCESS
PROPHECIES I CAN FIND BUSINESS
IMPROVEMENTS IN REAL TIME
THROUGH THIS EFFORT. THAT CAN
BE IMPLEMENTED BEFORE ANY MAJOR
IT UPGRADE IS TAKING PLACE. HIS
NAME IS NOT RE BRANDING OR
SEMANTICS IT IS INDEED A
PARADIGM SHIFT IN OUR THOUGHT
PROCESS. WITHIN THE BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION FRAMEWORK OUR
BOARDS IMPERIAL IS INITIATING
DRIVE THESE PROJECTS PARTNER
WITH ALL ASPECTS OF THE CA AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. DCA
BOTH PART AND PROVIDES
OVERSIGHT THROUGHOUT THE
BUSINESS MONITOR THIS
MODERNIZATION ACTIVITIES. EARLY
COLLABORATIONS INCLUDE THE
CREATION OF PROCESS MAPS AND
FUNCTIONAL REQUIREMENTS WITH
THE DCA ORGANIZATIONAL
IMPROVEMENT OFFICE. ADDITIONAL
CLOSE COLLABORATION OCCURS
THROUGH THE PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE THE PAL PROCESS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY.
AND PROJECT IMPLEMENTATION AND
EXECUTION OCCURS WITH PCA'S
OFFICE OF INFORMATION SERVICES
THE PILLARS OF BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION STRUCTURE ARE NO
NGUYEN DOCUMENT YOUR BUSINESS.
FOSTER AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
BUSINESS PROCESS IMPROVEMENT IS
ENCOURAGED ACTED UPON.
IDENTIFYING DOCUMENT BUSINESS
REQUIREMENTS FROM A PROGRAM
SPECIFIC PERSPECTIVE NOT AN
AMALGAMATION OF DEPARTMENT WIDE
REQUIREMENTS UNDERSTAND
RESOURCE DEMANDS AT EVERY STEP
OF THE PROCESS TO AVOID COSTLY
DIGITAL DELAYS. AND POTENTIALLY
CARVE OUT DEDICATED RESOURCES
WERE POSSIBLE. AND PARTNER WITH
KEY STAKEHOLDER GROUPS TO
EXPERTLY IMPLEMENT THE
INITIATIVE. OUR CURRENT
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION SYSTEM
IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINES RUN
FROM TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THOUGH I'D LIKE TO
CLARIFY THAT THESE TIME LINES
REPRESENT THE END OF THESE
RESPECTIVE PROJECTS. IF WE LOOK
AT THE TARGETED DATES FOR
INITIAL DELIVERY OF ONLINE
SERVICES TO PUBLIC CONSTITUENTS
THE TIME LINES ARE MORE
REFLECTIVE OF OUR AGILE
APPROACH. SIX BOARDS IN BUREAUS%
WILL IMPLEMENT INITIAL ONLINE
FUNCTIONALITY IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. FIVE IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO FOUR IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND ONLY ONE IN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. TO BE
SPECIFIC THE LONGEST PROJECT
DATE ONLY REPRESENTS ONE OF OUR
BOARDS. AND WE HAVE ALREADY
BEGUN ACTIVITIES WITH THEM WE
HAVE BEEN IN DISCUSSION WITH
THAT BOARD'S LEADERSHIP TWO X.
TO REFINE AND ACCELERATE THE
PROJECT DATES. THESE INITIAL
TIME LINES WERE DETERMINED WITH
A PRAGMATIC APPROACH OUR
PROGRAMS WERE ASKED TO CREATE
INVENTORY OF BUSINESS PROCESSES
WE OVERLAID A STANDARD DURATION
FOR THOSE BUSINESS PROCESSES.
WE THEN ADDED ON THE PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFECYCLE DURATION ON
THE AVERAGE PRICE OF PROJECT
APPROVAL I CYCLE DURATION. AND
THEN WE IMPLANT WE ADDED ON A
TWELVE OR EIGHTEEN MONTH
PROJECT EXECUTION. TIME LINES
WERE THEN OVERLAID WITH STAFF
CONSTRAINTS TO CREATE AN
OVERALL SEVENTEEN PROGRAM
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION
LANDSCAPE. OUR FIRST FOUR
PROGRAMS REFER TO AS BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION COHORT ONE
INCLUDES THE BOARD OF
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS LAND
SURVEYORS AND GEOLOGISTS THE
BOARD FOR PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION THE ACUPUNCTURE BOARD
AND THE BOARD OF CHIROPRACTIC
EXAMINERS. THESE FOUR PROGRAMS
UNDERTOOK BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION INDIVIDUALLY AND
THROUGH OUR STRUCTURE PROCESS
IDENTIFIED SHARED REQUIREMENTS
AND COST SAVINGS AREAS THAT
WERE BENEFICIAL ENOUGH TO MOVE
FORWARD IN THE PROCESS AS A
GROUP. COURT ONE HAS TARGETED
PROJECTS START DATE OF WINTER
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WITH A
FIRST RELEASE OF FUNCTIONALITY
THE PUBLIC SEVEN MONTHS LATER.
AN INCREMENTAL OR AGILE
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS WILL
DELIVER THE REMAINING
REQUIREMENTS EVERY FIVE TO SIX
SIX WEEKS THEREAFTER. ALL THE
REMAINING THIRTEEN PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE ENTERED BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION HAVE REALIZED
CONCRETE BUSINESS VALUE AHEAD
OF ANY NEW OR MODIFIED I. T.
SYSTEM. THE WORK PERFORMED BY
THE DCA ORGANIZATIONAL
IMPROVEMENT OFFICE TO IDENTIFY
AND DOCUMENT BUSINESS PROCESS
PERFORMING PROVEN ANALYSIS AND
OFFER RECOMMENDATIONS TO CREATE
BUSINESS REQUIREMENTS
SPECIFICATIONS HAS GARNERED
RAVE REVIEWS. I'M SURE YOU HAVE
MORE ABOUT THIS FROM ROBERT
COOLEY OF THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF THE BOARD OF CHIROPRACTIC
EXAMINERS LATER. I DID
PREVIOUSLY TALK ABOUT TIME
LINES THAT EXTENDED OUT. BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE'RE NOT
MAKING PROGRESS IN THE INTERIM
THERE ARE INCREMENTAL NEEDS
THAT ARE BEING MET NOW. OUR
APPROACH INCLUDES GROWING A
ROBUST ECOSYSTEM THAT OVER TIME
COULD BE MORE AGILE IN DEALING
WITH CHANGES IN SERVICE
DELIVERY. TO PROVIDE ONE
EXAMPLE OF THIS GROWING
ECOSYSTEM SINCE DECEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED AN ONLINE RENEWAL
POKE PORTAL FOR SIX OF THE
SEVENTEEN PROGRAM BORDEN
BUREAUS MARCHING THROUGH
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION. AND TWO
MORE WILL COME ONLINE WITHIN
THE NEXT FORTY FIVE DAYS.
RECENTLY THE BOARD OF PHARMACY
AT ONE OF AT A BOARD MEETING
REPORTED THAT 40% OF THEIR
RENEWALS WERE BEING HANDLED
WITH OR WITHOUT STAFF
INTERVENTION THROUGH THE ONLINE
PORTAL. THEIR EXACT THIS IS THE
SECOND YEAR THE PART POST
SECONDARY SCHOOLS WILL SUBMIT
SUBMIT ANNUAL REPORTS THROUGH
AN ONLINE PORTAL INSTEAD OF THE
PREVIOUS PAPER BASED AND MANUAL
PROCESS THIS HAS RECEIVED VERY
POSITIVE REVIEWS FROM THE
BUREAU SAID. SCHOOL POPULATION
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS A DC IT'S
OPEN DATA PORTAL LAUNCHED IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THIS
TRANSPARENCY INITIATIVE PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT STATISTICAL DATA
REAR OVER YEAR TRANS AND AN
INTERACTIVE INTERFACE FOR OUR
DATA PARTNERS AND THE PUBLIC
AND THE LAST EXAMPLE IS ALREADY
BEEN SPOKEN ABOUT BUT I WILL
SPEAK ABOUT THE CANNABIS
PROJECT THIS WAS A HIGHLY
VISIBLE AND COMPLEX PROJECT THE
VERY TIGHT MANDATED
IMPLEMENTATION DATE. WE WERE
SUCCESSFUL DUE IN PART TO THE
ASPECTS OF THE BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION DOCTOR THAT
OUTLINED TODAY THAT PARTICULAR
PROJECT WAS RECOGNIZED BY THE
TECHREPUBLIC TECHREPUBLIC IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WITH THE
BEST OF CALIFORNIA WARD AS AN
OUTSTANDING PROJECT AND WE WERE
WE RECENTLY FOUND OUT THAT WE
WERE ONE OF THREE FINALISTS FOR
NATIONAL. RECOGNITION FOR THE
SAME PROJECT. TO SUMMARIZE WE
HAVE DEVELOPED A METHODOLOGY
THAT WILL GUIDE THE LARGER DCA
COMMUNITY TOWARDS AN
ENVIRONMENT OF BUSINESS DRIVEN
THOUGHTFUL IMPROVEMENT. TO THE
WAY DCA BOARDS EMBARRASSED
DELIVER SERVICE TO THE PUBLIC.
WE BELIEVE WE ARE CREATING A
MODEL AT THE DEPARTMENT BY
WHICH OTHER PUBLIC AGENCIES CAN
FOLLOW. THANK YOU. THANKS CAN
YOU JUST CHECK OUT A QUICK STEP
BACK FOR ME AND JUST SUMMARIZE
WHAT WHAT ARE WHAT WERE THE
GOALS FOR THE VISITS MODERN
STATION PROJECT WHEN YOU TECH
LEADERSHIP THE GOALS FOR THE
BIZ MODERNIZATION. ALL TAKE A
LITTLE HALF THAT BACK IN STATE
TO CREATE THE BIT THAT
STRUCTURE A PLAN THAT COULD FIT
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS. IN BUREAU STRUCTURE
THAT WOULD BE SUCCESSFUL IN ANY
PROJECT GOING FORWARD AND TO
CLARIFY THAT THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAD IN BREEZE WERE BOTH
RELATED TO. WORK ACROSS THE
BOARD THE CHALLENGES WERE
ACROSS THE BOARD AND- ALSO
INCLUDED THE STRUCTURE THAT THE
STRUCTURE OF THE BOARDS AND
BUREAUS. SO BY KNOWING HAVING
KNOWLEDGE OF ALL THOSE
CHALLENGES I WANTED TO CREATE A
PLAN THAT WOULD. ENGAGE THE
BOARDS AND GROWS IN THE
STRUCTURE THAT WE HAVE. AND
CREATES. AND EMPLOYMENT ALL THE
LESSONS LEARNED FROM BREEZE SO
THAT WAS THE- IDEAS OF CREATING
A PLAN. AND THE GOALS WERE. ONE
FOR THE BOARD IN GROSS TO
IDENTIFY THEIR BUSINESS PROCESS
AND HAVE A VERY GOOD GRASP
THOROUGH GRASP OF THE BUSINESS
PROCESSES THEMSELVES. AND
BEFORE YOU DO WE JUMP TO I. T.
TO GO THROUGH AN IMPROVEMENT
PROCESS. BECAUSE WE'VE ALL
HEARD IT WHY'D YOU DO THAT WHY
DO YOU MOVE A FILE FROM ONE
DESK TO ANOTHER BECAUSE WE'VE
DONE IT THAT WAY FOR THIRTY
YEARS WE WANTED TO. MAKE SURE
THAT WE LOOKED AT THAT AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE IMPROVE THOSE
PROCESSES BEFORE WE IMPLEMENTED
INTO A POTENTIAL NEWTECHNOLOGY
PLATFORM. AND THEN ULTIMATELY
TO SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT THAT
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM SOME
SPECIFIC GOALS I SPOKE ABOUT WE
WANTED TO ENGAGE OUR
CONSTITUENTS WHERE THEY'RE AT
IN THEIR EVERYDAY ACTIVITIES WE
WANT OUR CONSTITUENTS TO BE
ABLE TO RENEW ON THE MOBILE
DEVICE. WE HAVE MOST OF OUR. I
HEARD A STATISTIC 71% OF
PEOPLE'S SOUL COMPUTING DEVICES
THEIR MOBILE PHONE AND SO ON IN
KNOWING THAT. WE WANTED TO MAKE
THE RENEWAL PROCESS WHICH IS
OUR LARGEST VOLUME TRACK ACTION
BY BY FAR AS EASY AS PULLING
OUT YOUR MOBILE PHONE
POTENTIALLY WITH ONE HAND AND
TO BE ABLE TO RENEW YOUR
LICENSE AND SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE STRIVING FOR WITH. ANY
NEW PLATFORMS TO COME ON
SPECIFICALLY COHORT ONE EVEN
THE BREEZE HAS A VERY WELL USED
AND. INTUITIVE INTERFACE FOR
RENEWALS WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE WERE JUST LIKE AMAZON
AND ALL THE OTHER UBIQUITOUS
ONLINE PLAYERS WITH REGARD TO
YOU TOO THE USER INTERFACE AND
EASE. GOT IT OKAY SO MOBILE
FUNCTION IT WAS IN A FROM A
CONSTITUENT PERSPECTIVE A
CONSTITUENT CALL. ANYTHING ELSE
IN TERMS AS- NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS FIVE PROCESSING
TIMES ALL OF THE S. APOLOGIZE
YEAH THAT. ARE THERE ANY
SPECIFIC THINGS YOU CAN SHARE
WITH US THAT YOU ALL SET OUT AS
GOALS THAT I IS A YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIAN. WEIGHED.
APPRECIATE SURE I'LL SPEAK TO
EACH OF THE STAGE ONE WHICH IS
THE PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE
FOR DEPARTMENT CONSUME UP
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY THE STAGE
ONE OUTLINES THE BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITY PROBLEMS AND
OPPORTUNITIES. ALL OF THE STAGE
ONES FOR THE SEVEN PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE COMPLETED THAT TODAY
ALL HAVE BASS LINE. TIME FRAMES
FOR APPLICATION PROCESSING AND
COMPLETE RESOLUTION WITH
TARGETS UP FOR. IMPROVEMENT I
KEEP I WOULD THROW OUT AT A
CAN'T REMEMBER A SPECIFIC
NUMBER BUT ALL THE BOARD SAY
STATE THAT WE CURRENTLY DO THIS
IN A HUNDRED AND TWO DAYS ON
AVERAGE AND WITH IT AFTER SIX
MONTHS OF IMPLEMENTATION OUR
TARGET IS TO DO IT WITHIN FORTY
NINE DAYS. JUST AS AN EXAMPLE
ALL OF THE STATE ONES HAVE
THOSE TARGETS FOR LICENSING
PROCESSING TIMES AS WELL AS
COMPLAINT TIME FRAMES AND MOST
IF NOT ALL OF THEM HAVE
INVESTIGATION TIME TARGET
BASELINE TARGET IMPROVEMENTS AS
THOSE AS THOSE GOALS AND- AT
THE PART WHEN THE PROJECT IS
FINISHED WE LOOK BACK TO THE
STAGE ONE TO MAKE SURE WE
CHECKED OFF THOSE BOXES TO ALL
THE OBJECTIVES. THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED EARLY OKAY GOT IT
THANK YOU. QUESTIONS AB MEMBERS
MISTER GLORIA. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION AND JUST THE FROM
THE TOP I'M GONNA KNOWLEDGE.
THIS IS TOUGH STUFF I DON'T
KNOW A LOT ABOUT TECHNOLOGY AND
WE FOR THE PEOPLE THAT ARE. BUT
WHEN REVIEWING THE LA COMMENTS.
THERE IS A SENSE IN YEAH I
UNDERSTAND I CAN ARGUE THE
OPPOSITE BASS TO COME AWAY FROM
A SENSE THAT THERE WAS A TEMP
WITH PRES OVER A LOT OF YEARS.
HE GOT SUPER EXPENSIVE IT
WASN'T EVER FULLY IMPLEMENTED.
NOW WE'VE MOVED TO BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION AND AT LEAST
WITHIN THE- THE CHART. RIGHT
THAT YOU YOU HAVE A REALLY LIKE
THE IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINE NO
FIRM. COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
SO CONVINCED ME THIS ISN'T
HISTORY REPEATING ITSELF. I CAN
ANSWER THAT I CAN ATTEMPT TO
ANSWER THAT IT'S- NOT IT'S NOT
HISTORY REPEATING ITSELF FOR A
COUPLE OF REASONS WE ACTUALLY
ALL OF THE LESSONS LEARNED FROM
BREEZE WE'VE IMPLEMENTED THE
HUNDRED AND 80 DEGREES OPPOSITE
OF THOSE STRATEGIES FIRST THE
ALSO ALL. ALL ONE SIZE ONE SIZE
FITS ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL WAS THE ROOF
BUT A ROUTE TO FOUNDATIONAL
PROBLEM AND THAT HAS BEEN. THAT
HAS BEEN CHANGED TO ALLOW. TO
ALLOW THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
BOARD EMBARRASSED TO SHINE
THROUGH IN THIS PROCESS SO LET
ME HOP IN THERE BECAUSE I WAS
IT SEEMS LIKE A DIFFERENT
PHILOSOPHY ONE SIZE FITS ALL
WAS FINE WITH PRES
IMPLEMENTATION NOW WE DECIDED
THAT'S NOT THE CASE. BUT YOU
HAVE THE FIRST TWO PHASES A
BREEZE. OUT THERE YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE THE FUNCTIONALITY FOR
THESE OTHER ONES THAT ARE NON
BREEZE A WELL PLAYED TO SOMEONE
IN YOUR ROLE YOURSELF OR OTHERS
OUR SUCCESSORS DECIDE. THESE
TWO NEED TO COMMUNICATE TO ONE
ANOTHER WE NEED TO GO BACK TO
ONE SIZE FITS ALL. IN WEEK THE
COULD NEW VENDORS ONLY TOO
HAPPY TO SELL US THAT
TECHNOLOGY AGAIN HAD
UNDETERMINED BUDGET OF COURSE I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
THE REASON AND I WON'T GET TOO
TECHNICAL PLEASE DON'T I WILL I
WILL. I'LL SAY THIS A WE'VE
ALREADY STARTED THAT EXACT IDEA
OF AN ECOSYSTEM AND- EVERYTHING
TALKING TO ONE ANOTHER WE
ALREADY HAVE BUT THE BREEZE
SYSTEM. TALKING TO THE MAIN
FRAME SYSTEM THAT THAT THE
OTHER SEVENTEEN BOARDS AND BE
OUR SHOES WE HAVE IT.
INTEGRATED BEEN TALKING FOR
REPORTING FOR ONLINE JUST
BEFORE THE OPEN DATA PORTAL
THAT I SPOKE ABOUT. SO ONE OF
THE REQUIREMENTS GOING FORWARD
A COHORT ONE AND HE BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION PLAN WHY FOR IS
THE INTEGRATION INTO THAT
ECOSYSTEM SO IT TALKS TO BRIEF
SO APPROXIMATE CAN. PLATFORM
AND ANYTHING ELSE THAT IT
EXISTS IT IS A KEY PART KEY A
KEY REQUIREMENT. SO WE DON'T.
WE DON'T MAKE SIDE LOAD NEW
SYSTEM OKAY WE MAKE AN ENTIRE A
COMMUNITY OF SYSTEM THAT IN
RATE. FOR COMMUNICATION. LA US
TO TEST. THE PEOPLE AT THE
HAPPIEST IN THE EQUATION THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS. THE STAFF
AND CERTAINLY THE TAXPAYERS ARE
NOT HAPPY SO ON THIS LAST PAGE
OF THE LA AS REPORT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE FIVE AND A
HALF MILLION THAT WAS IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. I RECOGNIZE THAT
ACCORDING TO THE TIME WHEN
YOU'VE PROVIDED THIS GOES OUT
TO TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SO YOU
HAVE. FIVE ADDITIONAL YEARS
WHAT'S THE PROJECTED COST I
RECOGNIZE IT'S DANGEROUS. GIVEN
THE ENVIRONMENT BUT- DOES
ANYONE HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT.
OVER ALL THESE YEARS WHAT THAT
FIGURE IS GOING TO BE TWENTY
FIVE MY SUCCESSORS SITTING HERE
WHAT WILL THEY SAID WHAT WOULD
THEY BE FACED WITH. IS A HARD
QUESTION TO SEE IF I CAN ADD AS
BEST I CAN. SO WE'LL TAKE A
BALLPARK FIGURE. AND I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE ONE FOR YOU I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
DISAPPOINTED BUT LET ME
EXPLAIN. SO WE HAVE SEVENTEEN
SMALL PROJECTS THAT ARE MOVING.
ON DIFFERENT TIMELINES SO
INSTEAD OF DOING ONE BIG
PROJECT WE'RE DOING SEVENTEEN
SMALL PROJECTS AND THAT'S THE
WAY IT'S BUDGET THAT'S WHY IT'S
APPROVED BY CALIFORNIA
BIOTECHNOLOGY. TO WAIT TO
PROVIDE DEPARTMENT ANTS. SO
WE'VE SEVENTY SMALL PROJECTS
MOVING. THEY ARE. LET'S SEE.
THE FOR PROGRAMS THAT JASON.
ALLEN THAT ARE IN THERE IT'S
THEIR AT THEIR. MOVING INTO THE
THIRD STAGE GATE WE'RE GONNA
GET A FIRM COST ON THOSE PRETTY
SOON. AND THAT'S THE FIRST
COHORT GOING THROUGH. THE OTHER
ONES ARE INCOME THE LEGISLATIVE
PARLANCE THERE IN THE FIRST
HOUSE POLICY COMMITTEE OR
THEY'RE JUST A BILL IDEA THAT
HASN'T EVEN BEEN ANALYZED YET.
SO YOU'RE ASKING ME NOW THE
CHAMBER THE SECOND HOUSE YEAH
FISCAL ON WHAT IS THIS BILL
REALLY COST AND I AM TRYING TO
DESCRIBE THAT WERE AT THE- END
OF THE THIRTY DAYS WHEN YOU'RE
BILLS AND PRINT BEGAN AMENDED
WHERE THEY'RE ON A BUNCH OF
THESE PROJECTS. IT'S TOO EARLY
TO ASK THAT QUESTION I THINK IS
ONE. OF THE SENATE MAY DO RIGHT
CORRECT. ASKING THE QUESTION
BECAUSE WITH BREEZE START AT
TWENTY MILLION ENDS UP
THREEFOLD OF THAT WE STILL
THINK IT WE WANT. ARE THE
CONTRACTS BEING CRAFT IN A
DIFFERENT WAY SUCH THAT THE
VENDOR MAY NOT GO BEYOND THEY
WERE EXPLAINING VERY CLEARLY
WHAT WE WANT THIS IS AN ALL IN
COST YOU BID FOR IT THAT'S IT.
I'M ARE WE LEAVING THESE OPEN
ENDED BECAUSE WHEN YOU AYE AYE
PRETTY THE NABLUS THIS OF THE
COST IN THE CHANGED ENVIRONMENT
BUT HE DOES A LOT YOU CAN DO TO
THE CONTRACTING VEHICLE TAKE
LESS ON THE HOOK FOR.
UNEXPECTED I'M SO I'M SO GLAD
YOU ASKED THAT QUESTION. I WILL
SAY THE CONTRACT STRUCTURE THE
IN. CONTRACT STRUCTURE. IS TO
DUPLICATE WHAT WE DID WITH THE
CANNABIS PROJECT OKAY AND IT
WAS A CONTRACT STRUCTURE. THAT
ALLOWED US TO MANAGE. RISK
THROUGH. THE CONTRACT ITSELF. I
WILL SAY THAT YOU. HIT ON THE
HEAD WITH REGARD TO A CONTRACT.
BEING FLEXIBLE AND WE DID NOT
HAVE THAT ARE IN THE BREEZE.
PROJECT HAD WE IT COULD HAVE
BEEN DIFFERENT IT WASN'T. AND
WE LEARNED FROM THAT. THE SH
THE CONTRACT IS SUCH THAT FOR
IT FOLLOWS THE AN AGILE
APPROACH. SO WHAT I MEAN BY
THAT IS WERE ABLE TO. IF IN THE
SECOND MONTH THE VENDOR COMES
IN AND IS NOT ABLE TO. DELIVER
WERE ABLE TO RID MANAGE RISK AT
THAT POINT. AND HAVE IT. WE'RE
NOT LOCKED INTO A CONTRACT AND
IT'S- I'M NOT GONNA SAY IT'S
OPEN AND IT'S JUST. THE
INTENDED STRUCTURE IS WAY MORE
FLEXIBLE. THAN IN THE PAST. AND
WERE ABLE TO MANAGE THE RISK OF
A- OF SPEND. TAXPAYER DOLLARS
ON THESE PROJECTS. DON'T
ANTICIPATE NOT SUCCEEDING HERE.
BUT WE DO HAVE THAT FLEXIBILITY
TO MANAGE THAT RISK CAN I
CLARIFY ONE THING FOR YOU YOU
WERE LOOKING AT THE- CHART THAT
TALKED ABOUT THE EXTENDED TIME
LINES. I JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT TO TIE THE BUDGET NUMBER
THE FIVE POINT FIVE. TO JUST
ONE PROJECT THE FIRST FOUR
COHORT ONE WHICH ISN'T THE
PROJECT COMPLETION IS TARGETED
FOR TWELVE THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE AT THIS POINT YES SO THAT
THAT ONE PROJECT FOR THE FOR.
IS TIED TO THAT TIME LINE TIED
TO THAT BUDGET YEAH AND THOSE
WITH THAT ADDS. UP. MISTER
SCHULTZ SAID WILL CONTINUE TO
PROBABLY GROUP TOGETHER THE
OTHER PRO THE OTHER PROGRAMS
BECAUSE THEY WILL BE SIMILARITY
IN REQUIREMENTS AND COST SAVING
AREAS. AND SO WILL. THAT COSTS
WILL COME TOGETHER AS WE GO
THROUGH STAGE GATE WITH EACH OF
THOSE PROJECTS THE NEXT ONE MAY
VERY BUILT VERY WELL BE FIVE OR
SIX PROGRAMS TOGETHER YEAH SO
WE'LL BE ABLE TO SHARE THAT.
ARE JUST TRYING TO YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW WHO THEY'RE GONNA CALL
IF THIS COMES IN AT A DIFFERENT
LEVEL RIGHT AND WHO'S GONNA BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND- YOUTH. I
MEAN ME RIGHT. THIS IS WHAT
MAKES US BUT ONCE TRY AND
UNDERSTAND LOVE FOR THE NEXT
COUPLE YEARS BE AT FIVE DOLLARS
FIVE MILLION WHICH MIGHT. BE I
THINK I CAN UP THE FACT THAT IS
NOT THE CASE THE FIGURE WILL BE
SOMETHING DIFFERENT. YOU
TELLING ME THAT THE CAN THAT
CONTRACTING VEHICLES WILL BE AS
TIGHT AS POSSIBLE TO YOU TO
MANAGE THE RISK. MY LAST
OBSERVATION WOULD JUST SIMPLY
BE THAT THE TIME HER EYES WERE
TOP TECHNOLOGY YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A SIX YEAR. HORIZON FOR
IMPLEMENTATION NO FEAR I HAVE
ALSO THAT IT WOULD JUST
EXPRESSES THAT OF COURSE SIX
YEARS NOT A LOT OF WHAT WE'RE
PLANNING FOR I RECOGNIZE IT'S
EARLY IN THE LEGISLATIVE.
PROCESS CAN CHANGE. BUT THAT
TIME AS IN. I WANT TO MS IN
INSTANTLY OBSOLETE HI. I'VE
TAKEN PLENTY OF THE TIMES AND
VENTURE THANK YOU FOR THE
INDULGENCE I WOULD JUST WRAPPED
UP BY AND I RECOGNIZE IT'S EASY
TO THROW STONES FROM OUTSIDE I
DON'T. HAVE ALL THE IDEAS OF.
EVEN I'M GREAT. PEOPLE. THE
QUESTION TO ANSWER. I WOULD ASK
YOU BY THE HARDEST PART
POSSIBLE YOU KNOW PUSH THE
VENDORS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
THESE COMPANIES HAVE THE MONEY
THEY CAN GET THIS STUFF DONE I
ALWAYS BET ON PEOPLE LIKE US
NOT STAYING LONG ENOUGH TO SEE
THE CONTRACT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH SO I HOPE THAT YOU ARE
BODY AND HERE FOR THE LONG HAUL
TO MAKE SURE THAT NO ONE GETS
CUTE. ON THESE DOLLARS I
APPLAUD THE GOAL OVERALL I
CAN'T THINK OF ANY I CAN'T
THINK OF A LOW HANGING FRUIT IN
TERMS OF BOLSTERING CONFIDENCE
PUBLIC AND WHAT THEIR STATE
GOVERNMENT IS DOING IN THE
MOBILE FUNCTIONALITY THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT I WISH
THAT THERE ARE OTHER INDICATORS
THAT THEY WOULD EXCEPT FOR
TRUST FOR ME BUDGET. EASE USE
AN AGE. WAS ON WHAT NOT. BUT
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO THIS
STUFF IS EASILY. I UNDERSTAND
BY YOUR TESTIMONY THAT YOU GET
THAT. YOU'RE WORKING NATURAL
DIRECTION. AND COMMUNICATING
THAT TODAY'S IS PRETTY IS A IS
A GOOD THING. NOW IT'S ALL THE
EXECUTION AND SO I WISH YOU
LUCK IN WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND I
HOPE. YOU DON'T FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE ANY STONES THROWN. ON
BY THE GET THE GENERAL SENSE
THAT VALUES REALLY IMPORTANT.
MAINTAINING A PHILOSOPHY OF
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO GOING FROM
ONE SIZE TO. DISTRIBUTE IT. I
WAS A NUMBER OF REASONS NO MORE
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER GORE AT
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
TO A SHARED I SHARES NUMBER THE
CONCERNS AROUND THE LACK OF A
CLEAR BUDGETS AND IT SEEMS TO
BE. STE IT'S A CRAZY LONG TIME
LINE SO. ANY THAT THIS THIS
ITERATION OF THE PROJECT
COMMENCED TWO YEARS AGO BUT
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR TEN
YEARS IT'S REALLY REALLYHARD
FOR ME TO WRAP MY ARMS AROUND
HOW IT'S POSSIBLE NOT TO BE
BEYOND THE SCOPING PHASE AND
NOT TO EVEN HAVE KIND A
BALLPARK FIGURE. ON HOW MUCH IS
THIS GOING TO COST AND- I DON'T
KNOW IF ANY OF YOU HAVE COME
FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR BUT I
CAN GUARANTEE YOU THERE'S NOT A
COMPANY IN THE WORLD. WHERE YOU
CAN SAY. I'LL WE GOT SAID. AND
PROJECTS AND WE'RE JUST GONNA
KEEP THE MALL RUNNING WE'RE NOT
EXACTLY SURE HOW MUCH THEY'RE
GONNA COST BED. JUST TRUST US
TO KEEP DOING THIS FOR SIX MORE
YEARS THAT. REALLY FEELS CRAZY
TO ME. AND I DO WANT TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT CAN WE DO TO. GET A
BETTER HANDLE ON HOW MUCH THIS
IS GOING TO COST AND- AND PUSH
FOR THAT CLARITY. AND SECOND. I
WOULD LOVE TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS
ON WHAT WOULD IT TAKE. TO TURN
THE STUFF AROUND IN YOUR TWO
YEARS INSTEAD OF SIX YEARS
BECAUSE I SHARE. YOU MISTER
GLORIA POINTED OUT. PROJECTED
TIMELINE. IT'S BUSINESS
REQUIREMENTS CHANGE THE WORLD
CHANGES IN SIX YEARS. MULTI
MILLION DOLLAR CORPORATIONS ARE
FOUNDED BELT SOLD SIX YEARS
THIS SEEMS REALLY REALLY TOO
LONG FOR ME TO A- IT'S JUST TO
TAKE A PLEA. PROCESS RE
ENGINEERING PROJECT BOB CHECK
IS THOSE ARE TWO QUESTIONS WHAT
WOULD IT TAKE FOR YOU GUYS TO
GET A BETTER IDEA OF AN OVERALL
BUDGET AND WHAT WOULD IT TAKE
TO DELIVER THIS PROJECT IN A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT WAY IN A
MUCH SHORTER. AMOUNT OF TIME.
TO GET TAKE TO GET TO A MORE
CONCRETE BUDGET FOR THE
ENTIRETY OF THE PROCESS. I'M
GOING TO SAY THAT. IT WOULD
TAKE A LOT OF GOOD ESTIMATES
AND BASS AND IT WE WOULD WE
WOULD HAVE TO BASE IT ON OUR
EXPERIENCE WITH CANNABIS AND
PERHAPS THE FIRST COHORT TO GET
TO. A CONCRETE FOR THE ENTIRETY
FOR THE ENTIRETY OF THE PROJECT
AND I EVEN HEDGING SAYING THAT
ONLY BECAUSE THE DIFFERENCES
THAT ARE VERY VERY APPARENT IN
OUR BOARDS IN BUREAUS THE SIZES
THE COMPLEXITIES THE BUSINESS
REQUIREMENTS. IT CETERA ARE SO
VARIED ALONG A SPECTRUM OF
EVERYTHING THAT WEEK AND THAT
COULD POSSIBLY THINK OF THAT TO.
PUT THE PUT EACH IN A BOX AND
COME UP WITH THAT A GOOD
ESTIMATE AT THIS POINT I WOULD
FEAR THAT THAT WOULD BE WAY
THAT NUMBER WOULD BE OFF OF HIM
HOWEVER ACADEMICALLY I THINK
IT'S POSSIBLE TO COME UP WITH
THE NEXT ESTIMATE BASED ON A
LOT OF COBB YACHTS AND- THAT'S
AND- ASSUMPTIONS. SOME PM AT
MID MATCH UP IN IN. I THINK WE
NEED TO TAKE THIS BACK AND I
UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION NIGHT
WHAT WILL COMMIT TO GETTING
BACK TO YOU I THINK. THE
CONCERN IS THAT AT THIS POINT.
IF PUSH FOR IT ESTIMATES WE
WOULD GIVE. AND ESTIMATE THAT
WE WOULD HOPE TO UNDERSTOOD
RIGHT WE WOULDN'T WANT TO GO
OVER BUDGET RIGHT SO WE WOULD
WHATEVER ESTIMATE WE DEVELOPED
AND- ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA WAS
JUST PUSHING US TO GET A GREAT
DEAL WITH THE VENDORS SO I KIND
OF DON'T WANT TO SEND A PRICE
SIGNAL IT'S BIGGER THAN WE
THINK WE CAN DELIVER GREAT SO
IT PUTS US IN A BOX SEAT RIGHT
IF. IF WE ESTABLISH AN OVERALL
BUDGET THAT'S THE OUTSIDE
BOUNDARY OF WHAT WE MIGHT SPEND
AND THEN WE'RE TRYING TO GET A
BETTER DEAL FROM THE VENDORS IT
PUTS US IN A IN A DIFFICULT BOX
THIS ALSO RELATES TO ACCOMPANY
APARTMENT TECHNOLOGY DEPARTMENT
FINANCE HOW THE WHOLE STATE
BUDGET THESE THINGS THAT'S A
LITTLE BEYOND MY REVENGE ISN'T.
SO WHAT. SAID TAKING A CALL.
BACK IN A GETTING BACK. THERE.
IT'S GOING TO ADD ONE ONE OTHER
LITTLE THING WHICH MIGHT MIGHT
HELP A LITTLE BIT. SEEMS LIKE
PART OF THE CHALLENGES. IS SORT
OF THIS PROJECT REAL LIFE CYCLE
PROCESS WHICH WAS PUT IN PLACE
FOR. YOU TO PROVIDE A REASON
FOR A LOT OF CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATE WITH THE PREVIOUS
PROCESS. BUT AS I UNDERSTAND
THAT USED TO ONE OF THE- PIECES
OF THAT PROCESS IS. IS THAT OF.
THROUGH THAT THAT PROJECT
APPROVAL ICICLE PROCESS. THAT
THE COSTS ARE REFINED INTO
THERE'S SORT OF AN- BY AT STAGE
TWO THEY HAVE THESE. ROUGH
ESTIMATES ASSEMBLY FOLKS
SOMEBODY'S ENTITIES ACTUALLY DO
HAVE YOU KNOW ROUGH ESTIMATES I
THINK A LOT OF MORE AROUND LIKE
MAYBE FOUR MILLION. EACH FOR
EACH THESE ENTITIES. SERVE IN
THAT BALLPARK ALTHOUGH IT COULD
VERY BRIGHT. BUT THAT'S A
PRELIMINARY ESTIMATE AND THAT
WILL WILL CHANGE OVER TIME
FINANCIALLY. AND SO THAT'S SORT
OF A STAGE TO BUT THEY DON'T
REALLY REFINE THOSE ESTIMATES
AND TELL ANSWER OF ACTUALLY
HAVE A FULL. PROJECT BUDGET
INTO REALLY THAT PROJECT
APPROVAL EXCEPT THE PROCESS IS
MORE TOWARD. THE END OF
COMPLETION. AND I THINK. THAT
IS IT SO THAT IT. IS A
REALISTIC. BOB PROJECT BUDGET
AND- THAT. IS SOMETHING WE. CAN
REALLY HOLD. ACCOUNTABLE AND
WHAT HAVE. YOU. THROUGHOUT THE
LIFE WHEN SHOULD YOU. ENGINE IS
YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE'S
PRESENTED WITH THE PROPOSAL'S
LIKE WE LIKE THE LEGISLATURE
SIGNED NINETEEN TWENTY IN THE
BUDGET FOR OKAY YEAH CAN YOU
PLEASE APPROVE THIS FIRST YEAR
OF FINDING RIGHT BUT AT THAT
POINT IS THE FIRST YOU'RE FUNNY
BUT- THE LEGISLATURE DOESN'T
REALLY KNOW WHAT THE TOTAL
PROJECT AS- THERE'S NO YEAH AND
SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT HARD SO WE
ACTUALLY HAD SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS AND I THINK
THESE ARE THINGS WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT AND WE
HAD SOME PREDICTIONS FOR SOME
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE ON THOSE.
ULTIMATELY WHAT INCLUDED BUT IN
THE BUDGET BUT I THINK THERE'S
A KIND OF THINGS LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO THINK ABOUT IS YOU
KNOW HOW DO WE HOW DO WE HAVE
THAT OVERSTAFFED. WE FIGURE OUT
HOW TO HAVE FUN THOSE INITIAL
ACTIVITIES BUT ALSO HOW DO WE
SORT OF NOT FIND MORE THAN WE
NEED TO WITHOUT A CLEAR THE ON
HOW MUCH THE PROJECT IS GOING.
TO COST AND WHETHER THAT'S
WORTH IT. AND SO THOSE ARE THE
TOP. THE LIGHT SAYS IT.
INSTRUCT. A LITTLE BIT AS WELL
THANKS A THAT SPAHN AND AT
MISMATCH HADDOCK. BUT I HAVE A
FOLLOW UP ON THAT CONCEPT SO I
COME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
AS A MATTER OF STANDARD
PRACTICE IN OUR MOST SIZABLE
PROJECTS PARTICULARLY AROUND
TECH IMPLEMENTATION OR BUILDING
STRUCTURES WE HAD A TWO PART
OUR FEE PROCESS AS OF THE FIRST
PART WAS SPECIFICALLY FOR
SCOPING OF THE PROJECT. AND AN
ESTIMATE WHICH COULD EVEN BE AS
I UNDERSTAND NOT WANTING TO
SIGNAL TO THE BIDDING MARKET
RIGHT THAT THAT THIS IS WHAT
YOUR RANGE IS BUT TOOK THAT
COULD BE USED AS AN INTERNAL.
KIND OF GUIDE POST IF YOU WILL
ESPECIALLY IN THESE MAJOR MULTI
MILLION DOLLAR PROJECT. IS THAT
A PRACTICE THAT. OCCURS NOW IS
AT A PRACTICE THAT YOU WOULD
BE. OPEN TO BECAUSE AGAIN ANY
GUARD RAILS THAT WE CAN SET IN
PLACE AROUND HOW WE'RE USING
THE PUBLIC'S MONEY. TO THE TO
THE BEST A FACT AND NOT KIND OF
WRITING THIS OPEN ENDED CHECK I
THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
THE COMMITTEES PRESENT HERE
TODAY TO TRY TO ESTABLISH. I
THINK THIS STRUCTURE THAT STAGE
GATE STRUCTURE FOR THE PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFE CYCLE. AND MAYBE
SEE A DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
COULD SPEAK TO IT A LITTLE BIT
MORE WHEN THEY IN THE SECOND
PANEL. IT DOES. BUT NATURALLY.
DIVIDE ITSELF INTO THE FIRST
TWO STAGES ARE THE PLANNING
EFFORTS. AND THEN THE SECOND
THE THIRD AND FOURTH STAGE ARE
THE- PROCUREMENT IMPLEMENTATION
EXECUTION STAGES. AND SO. THE
IT IS NATURAL IN THAT PROCESS
TO IF REQUIRED FIND THE INITIAL
STAGES AFTER AN APPROVED STAGE
TWO IS WHEN WE'RE ABLE TO GET
FUNDING FOR THAT THE PLANNING
STAGES. AND THEN THE THIRD AND
FOURTH IS WHEN WE GET PROJECT
FUNDING. AND ARE THE VENDORS
WHO VET WHO BID IN THE FIRST
PART OF THAT PROCESS THEN
ELIGIBLE TO BID ON THE RIM THEY
THE PROJECT ITSELF. POTENTIALLY
THEY WOULD BE DIFFERENT VENDOR
OFFERINGS THAT THE PLANNING
WOULD PROBABLY BE MORE PROJECT
MANAGEMENT BUSINESS ANALYST
TYPE OF FACILITATION WHEREAS
THE SECOND PHASE THE EXECUTION
WOULD BE. SYSTEM INTEGRATION
TECHNOLOGY TECHNICAL RELATED
CONTRACTORS. AND YOU WHO ARE
THE VENDORS THAT YOU'VE ENGAGED
WITH FOR THE MODERNIZATION PLAN
WERE GETTING READY FOR THE
STAGE THREE PROCESS WHICH
INCLUDES PROCUREMENT SO THAT
SOLICITATION IS STILL IT WILL
BECOME WILL BE OKAY FOR THERE'S
BEEN NO NEW NEW NEW VENDORS
APPOINTED AS YET. OKAY ENTER
WHO IS DOING STAGES ONE AND TWO
THAT'S BEEN AN INTERNAL EFFORTS
LED BY YOUR TEAM CORRECT. THREE
DIFFERENT PHASE IT THREE
DIFFERENT GROUPS WITHIN
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
AT A LARGE CONTINGENT OF
BOREDOM BUREAU I'M A CONTINGENT
ABOARD EMBARRASSED OFF ALSO.
WHO'S ON YOUR TEAM. I RUN THE
OFFICE EVEN FOR SO IT THE-
PEOPLE BANG ON THE KEYBOARD
BUSINESS ANALYSTS AT THE OFFICE
OF IMPROVE THE OFFICE
ORGANIZATIONAL IMPROVEMENT
OFFICE IS ADJACENT TO MY TO MY
GROUP. WHO FACILITATES THOSE
PROCESS MAPPING SESSIONS
PROCESS IMPROVEMENT ANALYSIS
AND SPECIFICATION REQUIREMENT
DEVELOPMENT. AND THEN WE
PARTNER WITH EVERY PRETTY MUCH
EVERY OTHER PLACE IN DC ALSO
LEGAL HR THOSE TYPES OF THINGS.
I THINK YOU IF THERE'S NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS FOR THIS
PANEL IT WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE
ON TO OUR SECOND PANEL THANKS
AGAIN FOR. JOINING US IN
OFFERING YOUR PERSPECTIVE. OF
THE SECOND PANEL IS GOING TO BE
TECHNOLOGY UPDATE AND BOREDOM
BUREAU EXPERIENCES. I THINK I.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND LET THAT THE
PALACE JANICE AND THEN
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING I'M
ROBERT COOLEY I'M THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THE BOARD OF
CHIROPRACTIC EXAMINERS JUST AS
THE FROM EXACTLY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER MANY MEDICAL BOARD.
JASON CHARLIE CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER DCI. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ANDREW WORKING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY PROJECT
APPROVALS IN OVERSIGHT. THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE I THINK
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
I HAVE. A BIT WITH MISS SPEARS
WE HAVE ANSWERS. NOW I'M
REPRESENTING YOUR MISTRESS
OKAY. IF YOU WANNA GO AND GET
STARTED IN THE- CURRENT
TECHNOLOGY THANKS SURE. SENATOR
MEMBERS. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY TO STATE
CENTRAL IT ORGANIZATION IS
BROAD RESPONSIBLE IN A FORTY
OVER ALL ASPECTS OF TECHNOLOGY
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT
INCLUDING POLICY FORMATION
INTERAGENCY COORDINATION IT
PROJECT OVERSIGHT INFORMATION
SECURITY. TECHNOLOGY SERVICE
DELIVERY AND ADVOCACY. THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CDT WHO ALSO
SERVES AS THE STATE CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER ADVICE IS
THE GOVERNOR OF STRATEGIC
MANAGEMENT AND DIRECTION OF
STATE IT RESOURCES. TTT WAS
ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
ESTABLISHING MAINTAINING AND
OVERSEEING THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE STATE'S IT STRATEGIC
PLAN. POLICIES STANDARDS
PROCEDURES AND ENTERPRISE
ARCHITECTURE. ADDITIONALLY
DEPARTMENT IS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
APPROVING AND OVERSEEING IT
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THEIR
LIFECYCLE WHICH MEANS THE
PLANNING THE BUDGETING THE
PROCUREMENT AND EXECUTION YOU
FOR AND FROM PREVIOUS BOARD UP
EXCEEDING THE PREVIOUS A PANEL.
SOME DESCRIPTION OF THAT. THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY ALSO
PROVIDES INFORMATION SECURITY
GUNS TO SECURE THE STATE'S
INFORMATION ASSETS. I HEARD THE
PREVIOUS ABOARD AT THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS MADE BY THE PANELISTS
AND IF I MIGHT COULD TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAD. AS I
SAID. I REPRESENT THE OFFICES
STATEWIDE PROJECT DELIVERY
WHICH IS ONE OF THE SEVEN
OFFICES WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY IN THIS OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE PROJECT DELIVERY IS
SPLIT INTO. TWO PRIMARY UNITS
THE INDEPENDENT PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFECYCLE OR PLANNING
ACTIVITIES. AND THEN UPON THE
COMPLETION OF THE PLANNING
ACTIVITIES. THE INDEPENDENT
PROJECT OVERSIGHT. DURING THE
PROJECT EXECUTION ACTIVITIES.
THE END OF THE PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE YOU HEARD A SPLIT IN
THE FOUR STAGES THE FIRST TWO
BUSINESS ANALYSIS WHICH IS THE
PROJECT CONCEPT AND-
DEVELOPMENT OF THE PROJECT
OBJECTIVES YOU HAD A SPECIFIC
QUESTION ABOUT OBJECTIVES
THEY'RE BASED UPON THE CONCEPT
OF SMART OBJECTIVES. MEANING
THEIR SPECIFIC. MEASURABLE
ACHIEVABLE REALISTIC AND TIME
BOUND. AND ACTUALLY QUITE
INSTRUMENTAL IN DETERMINING THE
PERFORMANCE OF THE PROGRAM
OUTCOMES AFTER THE TECHNOLOGIES
DELIVERED. THE. HELP PROCESS
WAS THE RESULT OF A TWENTY
THIRTEEN BLUE RIBBON PANEL
RECOMMENDATION SO IT WASN'T
HERE WHEN THE A BREEZE ORIGINAL
BREEZE PROJECT WAS LUNCHEON IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE AND IN FACT
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AS
IT IS TODAY WITH REGARD
OVERSIGHT IS NOT THE SAME AS IT
WAS A FEW YEARS AGO AND
CERTAINLY NOT WHEN THE BREEZE
PARTY FIRST LAUNCHED. SO IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN STAGE ONE
BUSINESS ANALYSIS OF ROLLED
OUT. AND THEN IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN STAGE TO WHICH FOCUSES
ON THE ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS.
WAS ROLLED OUT BILL TURNS
ANALYSIS TAKES A LOOK AT THE
POTENTIAL SOLUTION SPACE OF THE
PROJECT TECHNOLOGY. AND
ATTEMPTS TO IDENTIFY
ALTERNATIVES THAT NEED TO BE
EVALUATED BASED ON THE BUSINESS
NEEDS OF THE PROGRAM AREAS.
STAGE THREE AND FOUR WERE
ROLLED OUT IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
STAGE THREE FOCUSES ON THE
PROCUREMENT PROCUREMENT
ACTIVITIES INCIDENT THE
PROCUREMENT TO MAKE SURE THE
CONTRACTOR SET UP RIGHT. THE
STATE WIDE TECHNOLOGY
PROCUREMENT OFF THE STATE WHAT
TECHNOLOGY PROCUREMENT WAS A
NEW ADDITION JUST A FEW YEARS
AGO TO THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE
PROJECT DELIVERY WITHIN
OVERSIGHT. AND CAME FROM D. G.
S. AND ALLOW THE INFORMATION OF
THE DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY TO
FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON IT
SERVICES PROCUREMENT FOR THESE
LARGE TYPE OF PROJECTS. SO THAT
WAS IT AN ADDITIONAL
ENHANCEMENT THAT DIDN'T EXIST
IN IN TWO THOUSAND NINE D. G.
S. HAD THIRTY FOUR IT
PROCUREMENT. AND THEN STAGE FOR
IS FOCUSING SPECIFICALLY ON
FINAL ASSESSMENT AND APPROVAL
AND READING THIS FOR THE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT IN THIS CASE THE
BOARDS OF YOURS AND I THINK YOU
HEARD FROM. MISTER JOHNNY THE
FOCUS ON BUSINESS READING THIS
FOR THE BREEZE PROJECT. SO
THAT'S THE HEALTH PROCESS ONCE
THE PROJECT RECEIVED FORMAL
APPROVAL TO MOVE INTO ITS
EXECUTION PHASE. THE FOCUS
SHIFTS FROM THE FROM THE
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE TO
THE INDEPENDENT PROJECT
OVERSIGHT. ELEMENT AND I AM ONE
OF THE BRANCH CHIEFS FOR IN IN
THIS CASE OVER THE DCA FOR THIS
ACTIVITY FOR PROJECT OVERSIGHT.
AND WE FOCUS ON HI IN MEETING
CRITICALITY REPORTABLE PROJECTS
OR NON DELEGATED PROJECTS.
SPECIFICALLY TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROJECTS PERFORM ACCORDING TO
THEIR ORIGINAL AND BASELINE
PLANS FOR COST OF THE SCOPE AND
QUALITY. THE INDEPENDENT
PROJECT OVERSIGHT MANAGERS ARE
GENERALLY FULL TIME WITHIN THE
PROJECT ACTIVITIES WATCHING
WHAT'S GOING ON IN REPORTING
OUT MONTHLY TO THE STAKEHOLDERS
PRIMARILY THE PROJECT SPONSOR.
THE PROJECT DIRECTOR PROJECT
MANAGER AND THAT INFORMATION IS
TRANSPARENT AND PUBLISH MONTHLY
ON OUR I. T. TRACKING WEBSITE
SO WE CAN MONITOR THAT PROGRESS
I KNOW IT'S OF INTEREST TO THE
LA T'S OF INTEREST TO THE EAST
STATE AUDITOR AND OF COURSE THE
OTHER EXTERNAL CONSTITUENTS AND
STAKEHOLDERS LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ADDITIONALLY WE'VE ENHANCE THE
PROJECT OVERSIGHT FRAMEWORK BY
BRINGING IN. A FOCUS ON WHAT WE
CALL INDEPENDENT VALIDATION
VERIFICATION WHICH IS ANOTHER
ELEMENT WITHIN OUR TOOLBOX THAT
FOCUSES ON THE QUALITY OF THE
TECHNOLOGY BUILD TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE THAT THE THAT THE-
VENDOR IS BUILDING. THE RIGHT
TECHNOLOGY AND BUILDING IT WITH
SUFFICIENT QUALITY THOSE KINDS
OF PUTS A SURPLUS OF PROVIDE
THE BUSINESS NEEDS OR MEET THE
BUSINESS NEEDS OF THE OF THE
AGENCY OR THE DEPARTMENT. I
HAVE SOME OTHER COMMENTS
PREPARED BUT THE MORE SPECIFIC
IF YOU'D LIKE TO HEAR THEM NOW
OR I CAN WAIT UNTIL. YOUR
QUESTIONS COME FORWARD. YEAH
PERHAPS WE CAN CAN MEET OUR
OTHER PANELISTS OFFER THEIR
PERSPECTIVE AND THEN WE'LL COME
BACK TO THAT. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME WHERE. I GET MY NAME IS
JUST AS THE FROM AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICEROF THE
BATTERY MEDICAL BOARD HAS ALSO
PREVIOUSLY THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER. OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BOARD OF OPTOMETRY. BOTH
BOARDS WENT LIVE WITH BREEZE
AND RELEASED TO. IN JANUARY
TWENTY SIXTEEN. I ALSO SERVE AS
THE CHAIR OF THE CHIEF PRIESTS
CHANGE CONTROL BOARD WHICH
PRIOR TO THIS ALL CHANGES TO
THE PRE SYSTEM. I WAS THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE BOARD
OF OPTOMETRY THROUGH THE
ENTIRETY OF THEIR PRE SYSTEM
IMPLEMENTATION. AND
PARTICIPATED. IN NEARLY ALL THE
SYSTEM DESIGN DISCUSSIONS AND
DECISIONS. THE BREEZES THE
MODERNIZE OUR BUSINESS
PROCESSES BY BRINGING THEM ON
ALL ONLINE. THE BOARD OF
OPTOMETRY HAS ONLINE RENEWAL
RATE OF 84% THIS WAS LARGELY A
RESULT OF TARGETED OUTREACH AND
DESIGN DECISIONS THAT EXPLAINS
THE BENEFIT OF UTILIZING THE
ONLINE APPLICATION PORTAL. AS
OPPOSED TO A TIME CONSUMING
PAPER PROCESS. THE BETTER
MEDICAL BOARD HAS REACHED AN
ONLINE RENEWAL RATE OF 59%
WHICH I'M WORKING TO IMPROVE BY
IMPLEMENTING SOME OF THE SAME
OUTREACH STRATEGIES WE USE THAT
COME A TREE TO ACHIEVE SUCH A
HIGH UTILIZATION RATE. THE
REASON FOR PUTTING WITH EASE TO
USE ONLINE APPLICATION OPTION
IS CLEAR WHEN YOU CONSIDER THIS
FACT. 93% OF SE
ONLINE SEE THE RENEWAL APPROVED
IN LESS THAN A DAY. DURING MY
TIME AT THE BOARD OF OPTOMETRY
I SAW REAL BENEFIT FOR THE
FOCUS ON ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE
MANAGEMENT INTRODUCED DURING
RELEASED TO. WE THOUGHT FOCUSED
EFFORT ON BUSINESS PROCESS
ANALYSIS IN ON TARGETED AND
TIMELY. TRAINING THE BUSINESS
IN CHECK STRATEGY HAS PERSISTED
THREE OH TO OUR CONTINUING
MAINTENANCE OF THE PRE SYSTEM.
I DEVELOPED AN APPRECIATION FOR
THE BUSINESS WERE BUSINESSES
ROLE ON MODERNIZATION PROJECTS
DURING MY TIME IN IMPLEMENTING
BREEZE FOR THE PART ABOUT TOM
TREE. MUCH LIKE THE BUSINESS
MODERATION WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT
TODAY I REALIZE THAT THE
BUSINESS NEEDS SHOULD BE THE
PRIORITY DRIVER NOT IT. I'VE
BEEN AT THE VERY MEDICAL BOARD
FOR A YEAR AND I BEGAN TO
OVERLAY THESE IDEAS. FURTHER
DEVELOPING STRONG TIES BETWEEN
BOARD STAFF AND BREEZE
RESOURCES BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
REINFORCING THE THOUGHT THAT WE
MODERNIZE OUR BUSINESS
PROCESSES AND THEN LAYER ON
REQUIRED SUPPORT AND SYSTEMS.
TO THIS END WE HAVE RECENTLY
REDUCED OUR MULTI PATRON WILL
SET NEW WILL NOTICE DOWN TO A
SINGLE PAGE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGING OUR LICENSEES TO
UTILIZE OUR ONLINE SERVICES.
TOUTING INSUFFICIENCIES. I
MENTIONED EARLIER THE BETTER
MEDICAL BOARD HAS AN ONLINE WE
KNOW A GREAT A 59% THAT'S UP
FROM 49% OVER LAST YEAR. WE ARE
ALSO EXCITED ABOUT THE NEW
MODERN BUSINESS MODERNIZATION
STRATEGY THE BOARD HAS RECENTLY
BEGUN DISCUSSIONS WITH DC IRAN
MODERNIZING OUR FIELD
INSPECTION WORKS. ALL THE
QUESTIONS FOCUS ON BUSINESS
NEEDS AND NOT NECESSARILY
TECHNOLOGY THIS METHOD MORE
EASILY ENGAGES STAFF IN THE
PROCESS THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
EXPRESS THEIR NEEDS IN TERMS TO
UNDERSTAND WHICH WE BELIEVE
WILL CREATE A SUPERIOR PRODUCT.
I AM INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR
DISEASE QUIPPED PROHIBITING TO
ENSURE LESSONS LEARNED FROM OUR
ONE WERE USED TO IMPROVE
RELEASE TAIL. I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO THINK TO PERSONALLY THANK
THE ENTIRE BREEZE TEAM FOR
THEIR DEDICATION AND
DETERMINATION TO OUR BOARDS OUR
STAFF AND OUR STAKEHOLDERS.
WITHOUT THESE INDIVIDUALS
BREEZE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN AS
SUCCESSFUL IT WAS FOR MY
BOARDS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AN OPPORTUNITY SPEAK WITH THE
AND I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. QUICK TO FORGET TURN
NEXT PANELIST I JUST HAVE A
QUICK. CLARIFICATION QUESTION
SO SOUNDS LIKE FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE BY THE TIME WE GOT
TO RELEASE TO BREEZE WAS
ACTUALLY SMOOTH AND SUCCESSFUL.
YEAH THE WRECK. OKAY SO THEN
WHY DID WE- IF THAT'S THE CASE
WE KIND OF SPEND ALL THIS TIME
AND MONEY WORKING OUT ALL THE
BUGS WITH RELEASE ONE. RELEASE
TWO IS ACTUALLY SUCCESSFUL WHY
DID WE THEN ABANDON RELEASE
THREE AND COME UP WITH A WHOLE
NEW PLAN THAT'S LASTING AND
OTHERS. EIGHT YEARS. THE
SEVERING OF RELEASED THREE FROM
THE PROJECT WAS. A DECISION
MADE. AT DCA EXACT THE STATE
LEADERSHIP LEVEL IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN. SO I DON'T
ACTUALLY KNOW HIGH KIDS HOW
IT'S ANSWER THAT ONE. BUT AS
FAR AS ABANDONING THE- PROJECT
ITSELF IT WOULD IF WITH BEING
SUCCESSFUL I THINK. THE TENETS
OF THE BUSINESS MODERNIZATION.
FOCUS ON BUSINESS
ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE. TRAINING
AND OUTREACH WORTHY HALLMARKS
OF WHY RELEASED TO. WHAT'S SO
SUCCESSFUL AND SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY IN A LITTLE BIT
TECHNICALLY I APOLOGIZED THE
CHALLENGES THAT OCCURRED IN
RELEASE ONE I BELIEVE THE LA
TALKED ABOUT PERFORMANCE ISSUES
AND SO FORTH IN THE BREEZE ON
THE BREEZE PLATFORM STILL
REMAINED AT THAT TIME. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WE BELIEVE THAT
ADDING ON MORE BOARDS IN
BUREAUS AT THIS POINT TO BREEZE
IS DEFINITELY A POSSIBILITY BUT
AT THE PROP PLATFORM HAS TO BE
EXPANDED AND THAT. BREEZE IS
ABSOLUTELY AN ALTERNATIVE IN
EVERYONE OF THE BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION EFFORTS TO THE
PLANNING STAGES AN ALTERNATE
ANALYSIS INCLUDE BREEZE AS A
MAN AS A MANDATED ALTERNATIVE
IN ADDITION TO US THE CANNABIS
PLATFORM THAT WE SPOKE ABOUT.
AND THEN. OTHERS THAT MAY COME
ABOUT FROM MARKET RESEARCH SO
BREEZE IS ABSOLUTELY AN
ALTERNATIVE THAT IS BEING
LOOKED AT BY ALL OF THE BIZ
MODERNIZATION GROUPS OKAY GOT
IT AND WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE DECISION TO EXPAND THE
BREEZE PLATFORM IF THAT IS
INDEED. NEEDED IS THAT YOU.
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR EXPANDING
IT YES BUT WE WOULD YEAH
INFRASTRUCTURE LEE WE WOULD
EXPAND IT TO. POTENTIALLY
INCLUDE WHOEVER OF THE RELEASED
THREE BOARDS NEEDED CHOSE TO GO
ON IT WEATHER BUT THEIR- POWER
PROCESS LED THEM TO THAT
PLATFORM OKAY INTO MATT THAT
MANAGEMENT OF. THE BREEZE
PLATFORM ALSO FALLS WITHIN YOUR
PURVIEW CORRECT. RIGHT OKAY
THANK YOU I'M GLAD AND WITH
HUNTER NEXT PANELIST. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR CHAIRMAN
WELL IN MEMBERS I'M ROBERT
COOLEY OF THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
FOR THE BOARD OF CHIROPRACTIC
EXAMINERS ONE OF THE FOUR
BOARDS. IN THE BUSINESS
MONETIZATION COHORT ONE I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE OUR PERSPECTIVE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. THE NEED FOR
MODERNIZATION OF MY BOARD AS A
PARENT AND EAGERLY ANTICIPATED
BY OUR CONSTITUENTS WHO WANT TO
INTERACT WITH US IN THE SAME
MANNER AS THEY DO THEIR BANGKOK
OR ONLINE RETAILERS. FAST AND
UNCOMPLICATED AND THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF MENTION OF. AMAZON
THIS MORNING AND I AM AN ADULT
AMAZON PRIME MEMBER AND I
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS IN MY
EARLY TALKS WITH CHASE AND WAS
FEELING BECAUSE I'M NOT
TECHNOLOGICALLY SAVVY BUT I MY
EARLY CONVERSATIONS WITH JASON.
I KNEW WHAT WAS CAPABLE BECAUSE
OF MY ONLINE TRANSACTIONS WITH
PRIVATE ENTITIES AND SO I WAS
EXPLAINING TO HIM WHAT I'D LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO DO FROM PORT
PERSPECTIVES AND UP. JUST A
LITTLE SIDE NOTE THERE BUT. I'M
FULLY CLOSED TODAY THANKS TO
JEFF AS AS. I DON'T LIKE GOING
TO MALLS. THE CURTAIN THE
CURRENTLY OUR LICENSEES CANNOT
CONDUCT BUSINESS WITH THE BOARD
ONLINE NOR CAN THEY USE A
CREDIT CARD TO PAY FEES. THIS
IS BEEN A SOURCE OF FRUSTRATION
FOR LICENSEES. THIS THEIR
FRUSTRATION IS REGULARLY
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION I CAN'T
ATTEND A CONFERENCE OR MEETING
WHERE WITHOUT SOMEBODY SAYING
HOW COME I CAN RENEW MY LICENSE
IN WYOMING ONLINE BUT NOT
CALIFORNIA. SO IT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU KNOW I'M VERY EAGER TO
IMPLEMENT. NEED TO NEEDLESS TO
SAY THE BOARD AND I ARE
CHAMPIONS OF THIS MODERNIZATION
EFFORT BUT NOT WITHOUT INITIAL
ANXIETY CONCERNING THE
POTENTIAL FOR BUSINESS
DISRUPTION. OUR CONCERNS
WEREN'T AND REASONABLE THAT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS INTO THE EFFORT
OUR ANXIETY HAS BEEN A SWATCH.
I'VE COME TO LEARN THAT THE
ESSENTIAL COMPONENTS OF IT'S A
FULL BUSINESS MODERNIZATION
EFFORT OUR ORGANIZATIONAL
READING AS- THOROUGH AND
SPECIFIC BUSINESS REQUIREMENTS.
AND MODULAR PRIORITIZE CHANGE
OVER TIME THE MOST CRITICAL
ISSUE IS ORGANIZATIONAL READING
AS WHICH INCLUDES CONSIDERATION
SUCH AS IS BOARD MANAGEMENT
READY TO LOOKS EXPAND THE STAFF
TIME AND FISCAL RESOURCES
REQUIRED TO BE SUCCESSFUL. IT'S
STAFF READY AND ABLE TO BALANCE
THE EXISTING AN ONGOING WORK
FLOW DURING SIGNIFICANT CHANGE.
AND DO WE KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT
AND WHEN TO EXPECT IT. I CAN
CONFIDENTLY ANSWER YES TO EACH
OF THESE QUESTIONS THANKS TO
DCA IS EARLY AND ONGOING
SUPPORT. THE DEPARTMENT HAS
GUIDED. MY BOARD AND ME THROUGH
THIS PROCESS AND INSURED WE
UNDERSTAND THE SCOPE IN AMOUNT
OF RESOURCES REQUIRED BASED ON
THIS COMMUNICATION. I KNOW MY
BOARD KNOWS IN MY STAFF KNOWS
THE LEVEL OF EFFORT REQUIRED
AND THE LEVEL OF DESTRUCTION TO
BE EXPECTED. TO DATE THE BOARD
IS MAPPEDALL BUSINESS PROCESS
SEES CONSIDERED PROCESS
IMPROVEMENTS AND THOROUGHLY
DETAILED OUR BUSINESS
REQUIREMENTS. WE HAVE COMPLETED
STAGE ONE AND TWO OF THE
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE THE
MANDATORY PROJECT APPROVAL
PROCESS ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND ARE CURRENTLY
SUBMITTING STAGE THREE WHICH
INCLUDES PROCUREMENT. OUR
CURRENT TIME LINES TARGET THE
PROJECT EARLY SO PROJECTS START
DATE OF DECEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN AND INITIAL ONLINE
FUNCTIONALITY FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS BY JULY TWENTY
TWENTY FROM A BUSINESS
PERSPECTIVE THE BOARD IS READY
TO MODERNIZE IN ORDER TO BETTER
SERVE OUR CONSTITUENTS.
PRESIDENT MINUTE DON TECHNOLOGY
NON TECHNOLOGICALLY SAVVY
ADMINISTRATOR I WAS DAUNTED BY
THE PROSPECT OF NAVIGATING THE
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION PROCESS
HOWEVER WITH CDT IN DC A
LEADING THE WAY. THE PROCESS
HAS BEEN PAINLESS AND
INFORMATIVE AT TIMES IT'S BEEN
EVEN ENJOYABLE THEIR EXPERTISE
AND COMPETENCE ARE APPARENT I
HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE IN THEIR
ABILITY TO GUIDE MY BOARD
THROUGH THE FINAL PHASES OF THE
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION PROCESS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. DID IT SURPRISE YOU WHEN
YOU STARTED TO GET THOSE
TIMELINE TO SEE THAT IT WAS
GONNA BE LIKE A FIVE YEAR
PROJECT. TO BE HONEST A FEW
YEARS AGO WHEN THEY SEVERED
RELEASE THREE I HAD NO IDEA IF
AND WHEN WE- WE WOULD BE
BROUGHT INTO I WAS ASSUMING
THAT EVENTUALLY WE WOULD BE YOU
KNOW. THAT KIND OF FOOTBALL
THAT IN THE BREEZE AND NOW I
FIND OUT THAT WE HAVE WE HAVE
OPTIONS WE MAY END UP USING
PRES BUT WE YOU THROUGH THIS
MODERNIZATION PROCESS WE
DETERMINE WHAT WE NEED. AND SO
THIS IS ACTUALLY MOVING ALONG
QUICKER THAN I ANTICIPATED
BECAUSE IT IS A THE DEPARTMENT
ASKED ME HERE ARE YOU KNOW
WE'RE STARTING THE BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION PROCESS. ARE DO
YOU WANT TO JUMP IN EARLY AND I
WAS MORE THAN HAPPY TO AND IT'S
GONE ALONG QUICKLY IN FACT. I
AM MONITORING MY BUDGET CLOSELY
BECAUSE WE RECENTLY REYES FEES
AND THIS THIS CAME ABOUT SOONER
THAN I EXPECTED SO MIGHT FUND
HASN'T HAD A CHANCE TO FULLY
RECOVER AND- AND SO I AM. IT
WOULD BE IT IT'S GOOD THAT
WHERE THE PUT IT THAT WAY IN
THE MONEY IN STAGES AND I YOU
KNOW I MONITOR MY BUDGET DID
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE STAY
WITHIN BUT IT'S- IT THE THAT'S
JUST SOMETHING THAT I WAS AND-
THEN. NECESSARILY PLANNING ON
GOING FORWARD THIS QUICKLY I'M
HAPPY THAT I'M GOING FOUR FOR
THIS QUICKLY BUT IT'S HERE SO
IT IT SEEMS LIKE A LONG TIME
WHEN YOU'RE STANDING AT THE
BEGINNING. BUT NOW WITH WE'RE
IN THE MIDST OF IT AND ALSO
WITH THE WITH THE NIMBLE MISS
OF THE PROJECT IS JASON WAS
STATING WE CAN ADD ON THAT IS
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO.
ADD ON SOME FUNCTIONALITY
BEFORE WE'VE AND PROCURE THE
NEW SYSTEM AND IT WILL TO WERE
CONTRACTING THE VANITY CREDIT
CARD PAYMENTS IN MY RENEWALS.
AND SO THAT FUNCTIONALITY THAT
WILL BE ABLE TO OFFER. EARLY
NEXT YEAR. AND THEN WE CAN.
APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE BUT BUT I
A I TOLD THEM I WANT TO BE ABLE
TO DO THIS I WANT I WANTED TO
INCORPORATE CONTINUING
EDUCATION AND HAVE EVEN NON
LICENSEES LIKE OUR CONTINUING
EDUCATION PROVIDERS AND SCHOOLS
BE ABLE TO INTERACT WITH US
ONLINE TO TRANSFER RECORDS AND
SO ON. I COULD SEE JASON'S EYES
LIGHTING UP IN HE TOOK A PIECE
OF PAPER AND HE WROTE THIS
ROUGH TRADE DIAGRAM AND THERE
WAS AN AREA IN THE MIDDLE AND
HE WAS SHOWING ME HOW WE CAN DO
THESE. THINGS HERE AND THEN WE
HAVE THIS AND AGAIN I DON'T
KNOW THE TERMS OF. IT HE SAID
WELL YOU KNOW WE HAVE THIS THIS
AREA HERE IN THIS ALL BE
HAPPENING HERE ANDTHEN WE CAN
TRANSFER THAT INTO THE NEW.
SYSTEM AND I UNDERSTOOD EIGHT I
KNEW HE UNDERSTOOD WHAT I
NEEDED AND I UNDERSTOOD WHAT.
HE WAS TELLING ME WE CAN BE
ABLE TO DO AND SO AND IT'S
GOING ALONG AS EXPECTED SO I'M
NOT DAUNTED BY THE TIME LINE
IT'S WILL BE THERE. WILL BE
THERE SOON ENOUGH. YOU
MENTIONED ABOUT ABOUT DATE
EXPECTED EXPENDITURE SO HOW
MUCH HAVE YOU SPENT SO FAR ON
PHASE ONE AND TWO. WHAT ARE YOU
EXPECTING FOR PHASE THREE AND
FOUR WHERE. WE'VE SPENT. ABOUT
TWO MILLION WE'VE- WE'VE HAVE
APPROPRIATED. AND I AM HOPING
THAT WE STAY WITHIN THE FIVE
MILLION RANGE I I'M CONFIDENT
WE WILL. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
FOR MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT.
WE CAN. WE CAN CHOOSE HOW. WE
MOVEALONG SO WE DON'T HAVE TO
ADD ALL THE FOLLOW THE
FUNCTIONALITY AT ONCE AND SO.%
THAT YOU KNOW THAT CAN HELP
MITIGATE THAT AND- DELAYED
CERTAIN COSTS BECAUSE WILL BE
IT WILL BE. PROVIDING SERVICES
AND. YOU KNOW LIKE WITH THE
ONLINE RENEWAL INITIALLY WILL
BE DOING THAT THROUGH A VENDOR
WHO IS PROCESSING AND
EVENTUALLY WILL BE ABLE TO
PROBABLY. DO THAT I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE WOULD NEED A VENDOR
ACTUALLY TO CLARIFY THEIR THE
ONE OF THE TO ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMS THAT WE SAID WHAT I
SAID EARLIER WAS ON GOING ON
THE ONLINE RENEWAL PORTAL THAT
WE CREATED IN DECEMBER TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. THEY'RE
ACTUALLY GONNA BE GOING WITHIN
THE NEXT THIRTY DAYS ON THAT
THAT WAS A- INTERNAL RESOURCE.
INTERIM FUNCTIONALITY DELIVERY.
SO AND THAT'S- YOU'RE JUST THAT
THESE INTERIM STEPS THAT WE CAN
TAKE AND THEN IT'LL EASE THE
TRANSITION WHEN WE HAVE A NEW
SYSTEM OF WILL BE ABLE TO
TRANSITION THE THAT
FUNCTIONALITY OVER TO THE NEW
SYSTEM BUT- FROM WHAT I'VE BEEN
EXPLAINED IT'S OUR LICENSEES.
LIKELY WON'T SEE THE DIFFERENCE
THIS WILL BE HAPPENING BEHIND
THE SCENES AND WHEN THEY GO TO
OUR WEBSITE EVERYTHING LOOKED
THE SAME THE PROCESS WILL BE
THE SAME. BAD WILL BE ABLE TO
TRANSITION AT THAT TIME AND SO
I LIKE THAT FACT THAT WE CAN
YOU KNOW IT IS MORE
CUSTOMIZABLE THERE IT'S- IT WE
CAN WE CAN BE MORE NIMBLE AND-
HI SO I'M VERY HAPPY WITH THE
PROCESS. AND YOU MENTIONED THAT
THE EFFORT FOR SOME OF THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT YOU SERVE ON
ON RENEWAL AND BEING ABLE TO
USE CREDIT CARDS OR YOU TO THAT
PRIORITIES AND IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET SOME
RELATIVELY QUICK. WINS THERE
WITH THIS IN TERMS LUCIEN ARE
WE RULING OUT THAT. OF INCOME
SOLUTION. ACROSS THE BOARD SO
THAT. EVERYONE CAN CAN HAVE
THAT EVEN IF IT IS JUST IN TRAM.
YES ABSOLUTELY WE'VE IN GAUGE
WITH ALL OF THE PROGRAMS AND
THE I THINK I SAID SEVEN A
SEVEN TOTAL PLUS TWO MORE OUT
OF THE SEVENTEEN WILL BE ONLINE
WITHIN THE NEXT TO TWO WEEKS
I'M SORRY THIRTY DAYS OF THE
REST OF IT WILL BE IN A FLOW
BASIS OVER THE NEXT. I WOULD
SAY THREE TO FOUR MONTHS THE
WORD AGAIN WORKING WITH THEIR
READINESS AND THEIR ABILITY TO
ENGAGE WITH US TO COME UP WITH
THE RIGHT THE- QUICKER
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT SORT OF
THING. OKAY GREAT BUT YOU'RE
WORKING TO IGURE OUT YOU KNOW
ARE THERE IN TRUMP DELIVERABLES
THAT CAN. OUT ALL THE TIME THE
LEVERAGE YOU HIGH THE PHONE NOW
WRITER AUDIENCE OKAY. GREAT AND
THE DEPARTMENT HAS AND THAT'S
THAT'S BEEN CRITICAL BECAUSE AS
YOU MENTIONED ONLINE RENEWAL IS
THE BIGGEST ISSUE FOR LICENSEES
THEY THEY ALL WANT. TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT AND WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO ACCEPT ONLINE PAYMENTS
BECAUSE IT'LL SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE OUR MAIL ON MONDAY
MORNINGS WE HAVE ONE PERSON
THAT SPENDS THE MAJORITY OF THE
MORNING OPENING THE MAIL AND
IT'S MOSTLY RENEWALS. AND IF WE
GET CUT THAT EVEN IN HALF NINE
TO STATE IT'LL BE MORE THAN
HALF WE WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY CUT
WORKLOAD WE COULD DIRECT THOSE
STAFF RESOURCES ELSEWHERE. I
HAVE A SMALL PROGRAM TWENTY
EMPLOYEES TOTAL SO THAT'S HUGE
ONE WE'RE ABLE. TO REALIZE
THOSE EFFICIENCIES THAT CUT THE
MANUAL PROCESSING. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. SO FOLLOWING UP ON
AT AN EARLIER CONCEPT MENTIONED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA I
THINK ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE
HAVE PARTICULARLY HEARING
CALIFORNIA HOME OF SILICON
VALLEY IS THAT TECH CHANGES SO
RAPIDLY SO FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S KNOWLEDGE BASE
ARE THERE MEASURES THAT CAN BE
TAKEN TO STREAMLINED THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF NEW TECH.
IMPLEMENTATION ACROSS OUR
AGENCIES FIRST OF ALL AND
SECOND. IF SO OR IF NOT ARE
THERE STATUTORY OR STRUCTURAL
BARRIERS THAT PREVENT A MORE
RAPID IMPLEMENTATION THAT WE
SHOULD BE AWARE OF AND BE KIND
OF ON THE CUTTING EDGE OF
CHANGING BECAUSE MY CONCERN IS
A LEGISLATOR IS YOU KNOW WE
WILL SEE ANOTHER NEW WAVE OF
TACK ARRIVING AT OUR DOORSTEP
ANYTIME NOW PARTICULARLY AROUND
FINTECH FINANCIAL TECH WHICH IS
GOING ALSO IMPLEMENT THEN
IMMEDIATELY PAYMENTS AND
PROCESSING SO MUCH OF WHAT
YOU'RE AGENCIES DO. SO IF YOU
COULD SPEAK TO IS THERE ANY WAY
THAT WE CAN TO HELP YOU KIND OF
CONSOLIDATE STREAMLINE THIS
PROCESS AND BE ABLE TO RESPOND
TO TECH ENHANCEMENTS IN REAL
TIME AND TO BE ABLE TO BETTER
CONSERVE TO SERVE THE CONSUMERS
THAT. APPRECIATE HEARING THAT.
ALL ALL TEND TO ANSWER THAT I
THINK THE ACT OF ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'VE SEEN IN THE
LAST THREE TO FOUR YEARS. IS AN
EXPANSION OF THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGIES STATEWIDE
CONTRACTS LEVERAGED PROCUREMENT
CONTRACTS THAT EXIST THAT ALLOW
DEPARTMENTS LIKE MINE LIKE. THE
CA TO MORE EASILY PROCURE OF
COMMODITIES UNDER THESE
LEVERAGED PROCUREMENT I THINK
THE EXPANSION OF THAT OR OR
JUST THE MAINTENANCE OF THAT
IN. THE AREAS OF TECHNOLOGIES
THAT ARE CUTTING EDGE MOST
RELEVANT MOST IMPACTFUL TO A
STATE GOVERNMENT MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE I KNOW THAT IF I CAN
PURCHASE SOMETHING OFF OF. FROM
ONE OF THOSE PROCUREMENT
METHODOLOGIES IT'S- A LOT
QUICKER THAN IF I HAD TO GO AND
A DIFFERENT WAY. SO THAT'S THE
FIRST THING THAT COMES TO MY
MIND THE SECOND I WILL SAY THIS
AT ALL IN AND MAKE IT WITH A
NEGATIVE CONNOTATION. BUT TO
TALK STE THE TIME LINES AS A
WHOLE AND THE ABILITY TO BE AS
AGILE AND NIMBLE AS POSSIBLE.
WE STILL. BUT WORK WITHIN.
STRUCTURES THAT EXIST THE LA
SPOKE TO THE BUDGET CYCLE AND
IT'S OF OVERLAY ON TECH
PROJECTS AND THE APPROVAL OF
TECH PROJECTS. SO WE HAVE THAT
TO WORK WITH AND WE ALSO HAVE
THE PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE
WHICH- I AS SOMEBODY WHO IS ON
THE RECEIVING END OF THE
OVERSIGHT I'D RATHER SEE
OVERSIGHT. YOU KNOW AS LEAN AS
POSSIBLE HOWEVER THE REALITY IN
IT SINCE THE PROJECT APPROVAL I
CYCLE HAS COME ABOUT IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN IN MY
EXPERIENCE WITH IT IT HAS PUT
IT HAS THEY HAVE PARTNERED WITH
US. TO MUCH MORE THOROUGH AND
SUPERIOR AND PRODUCTS AND WHEN
I SAY THAT NOT NECESSARILY JUST
THE END PRODUCT OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION BUT THE PLANNING
ARTIFACTS THE PROJECT
ARTIFACTS. AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE. MR WHARTON SPOKE ABOUT
SCOPE COST SCHEDULE AND QUALITY
AND THAT'S THE LAST ONE IS ONE
THAT IS OFTEN FORGOTTEN SO THAT
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE PUT
EYES ON. PUT PUT MULTIPLE EYES
ON THAT PROCESS AND I SEE THINK
WE FIT WE'VE SEEN THAT SO. THAT
WAS A LITTLE BIT OF A SIDE STEP
TO YOUR QUESTION BUT THE THINGS
THAT BECAUSE THAT'S A BIT OF A
LINK TO YOUR PROBABLY IF YOUR
TIME ARE. THOSE TO THOSE ITEMS
BUT AGAIN NOT SAYING THAT IT'S
A NEGATIVE THING BECAUSE I
FOUND JUST A TON OF VALUE BEING
ON THE OVERSIGHT END OF THAT
PROCESS SINCE IT'S COME OUT AND
THEY REFINED IT OVER. THE LAST
FEW YEARS. TO ROUGH OUT SOME
EDGES AND JUST BRING MORE
RELEVANT INSIDE AND FEEDBACK TO
THAT PROCESS. AND WE'RE. IN THE
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION WERE
VERY CLOSE PARTNERS WITH CDT.
TO THE BENEFIT OF THE
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS
DEFINITELY. IF I A MAJOR SAID I
MY UNDERSTANDING IS OUR NEW
SYSTEM WILL BE ADAPTABLE AND
THE NEW TECHNOLOGY COULD
ESSENTIALLY PLUG AND TO SO WE
CAN ADVANCE WITH THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT THAT'LL BE THE CAPABILITY
GOING FORWARD SO THIS ISN'T
GOING TO BE OBSOLETE. BY THE
TIME WE YEAH WE PROCURING AND
GET IT IMPLEMENTED IT'S GOING
TO BE ON TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN.
EXPAND YES THANK YOU AND THAT
WAS THE SECOND PART QUESTION I
APOLOGIZE I THINK IN CHOOSING.
TECHNOLOGY THROUGH THIS PROCESS
IN ORDER TO FUTURE PROOF WHICH
IS KIND OF YOUR QUESTION HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
SPEND A DOLLAR TODAY AND ITS
ITS VALUE LIST TOMORROW WE DO
THAT WE ATTEMPT TO DO THAT
BASED ON THE AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGY THAT EXISTS TODAY.
HOW MUCH OF IT IS ADAPTABLE HOW
QUICK TO MARKET OUR CHANGES
HUGELY IMPORTANT AND I THINK
WAIT A PART IN IT IN A
TECHNOLOGICAL ARC THAT ALLOWS
US WITH PLENTY OF TECHNOLOGIES
PLATFORMS THAT EXISTS TODAY A
LOT OF HAS A SERVICE WE MAY BE
COULD BE MAY HAVE HEARD OF
SOFTWARE AS A SERVICE PLATFORM
AS A SERVICE. CLOUD CLOUD
APPLICATIONS THAT WERE AT WERE
IN AN ARC IN TECHNOLOGY THAT
MAY THAT WE BELIEVE ARE
CONFIDENT MAY ALLOW US TO
CHOOSE A TECHNOLOGY THAT WILL
MAKE US AS FUTURE PROOF AS IS
REASONABLE SO THAT WE CAN. WE
CAN VALUE THE IT INVESTMENT FOR
YEARS BUT ALSO WHEN IT'S TIME
TO CHANGE IT WAS TIME TO ADAPT
WERE ABLE TO DO THAT WITH AS
LITTLE DISRUPTION AS POSSIBLE.
THE ECO SYSTEM IDEA THAT I
BROUGHT UP EARLIER. WHAT HE
JUST EXPLAINS WHAT I WAS TRYING
TO EXPLAIN EARLIER IN MY
PRESENTATION IS JUST THAT THAT
ADAPTABILITY AND PLUGGING IN
THESE SERVICES AND WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO DO THAT. AT
ON THE FRONT END BUT BUT WILL
HAVE THAT CAPABILITY TO ADAPT
AND TO ADD ON GOING FORWARD SO
TO ME THAT'S VERY ENCOURAGING
I'M EXCITED ABOUT. CORRECT ME
FOR MODEST BUT BREEZE HAS THE
CAPABILITY RIGHT NOW TO BE
ADAPTABLE SO WHEN WE ARE
LOOKING AT. OUR INSPECTIONS AND
THE AMOUNT OF TIME THE
PAPERWORK TAKE UP OUR
INSPECTORS TO DO WE ACTUALLY
HAD DECENT SEEN COME OUT AND DO
A RIGHT ON INSPECTIONS AND
WATCH THE PROCESS AND THEN WE
CAN DISCUSS. THE BEST WAYS TO
IMPROVE THAT PROCESS BY
BUILDING ON TO BREEZE ARE
POTENTIALLY GET OTHER SOFTWARE
THAT WORKS WITH BREEZE. SO I
DON'T THINK THAT BREEZE ITSELF
IS OBSOLETE BECAUSE IT IS A
DOCTOR PULLED CORRECT. SHE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT I THINK THE
IDEA OF THIS ECO SYSTEM THAT I
KEEP SPEAKING ABOUT. PLUGS
BREEZE AND THE CANNABIS
PLATFORM INTO THAT. ENVIRONMENT
FOR FOLKS TO USE TO USE AND TO
ADD ON TO BOLT ON TWO DIFFERENT
FUNCTIONALITIES. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE WE FOUND
GENERALLY THE TECHNOLOGIST
ACROSS MY CAREER. IS THAT
NGUYEN AND IT WOULDN'T AGENCY A
COMPANY INVEST A LOT IN A
PLATFORM OF SOME SORT. THEY
ATTEMPT TO SHOVE EVERY
POTENTIAL BUSINESS OP BUSINESS
PROCESS INTO THAT SYSTEM
BECAUSE THEY- SPENT A INVESTED
IN IT. AND SOMETIMES A REALITY
IS MULTIPLE SYSTEMS ARE THE-
ANSWER TO. A PROVIDING A
HOLISTIC OPERATIONAL DOES IT
OPERATED OPERATIONAL IS ATION
OF YOUR PROCESSES. SO BREEZE
FITS RIGHT INTO THE ECOSYSTEM
TALKS TO. X. Y. AND Z. TO
ACHIEVE AN OVERALL OPERATION
FOR THE BOARD OF. INSERT BOARD
HERE. PHARMACY VET MED
CHIROPRACTORS ETCETERA. SHOULD
BROUGHT THAT ROUGH DRAFT THAT
YOU DID FOR ME BECAUSE IT HE
EXPLAINED IT SO WELL AND THAT
YOU JUST AS LITTLE DRAWING OUT
OF PAPER AND IT WAS EASILY
UNDERSTANDABLE AND I GET FOR ME
WHO KNOWS NOTHING ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY. I KNEW WHAT HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT AND WHAT WE COULD
DO AND SO IT MADE ME EXCITED
ABOUT THE PROCESS. IT'S GOOD
YEAH IT'S WONDERFUL TO SEE
EFFECTIVE. PARTNERSHIPS WE'RE
TACKLING SOME OF THESE REALLY
HARD. BAKE AT ISSUES SUCH AND
THAT'S GREAT TO HEAR IN FROM
STARTED REPORT ONE OF THE
THINGS I'VE BEEN REALLY
IMPRESSED WITH THIS THE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT AND CD T. AND THE
BUREAU OF AUDITS AND OUR AGENCY
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING I MEAN EVERYBODY IS
ENGAGING AND- PARTICIPATING IN
THIS PROCESS SO WE ALL NOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN WHEN AND
THERE WON'T BE ANY SURPRISES
FOR ANYBODY IT'S REALLY A
PRETTY IMPRESSIVE HOW IT'S
WORKING OUT. JUST CHECKING BACK
ONE MORE TIME THAT THIS
QUESTION A TIME LINE AB THIS
LITTLE. THIS GUY. ARE THERE
THINGS WE COULD DO SO THIS HAS
SAID HAVE FLOW CHART OF WHEN
THINGS ARE GONNA GET ROLLED OUT
WITH PHARMACY BEING DELIVERED
IN JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
ARE THERE THINGS THAT WE CAN DO
TO COME PROCESS AND OTHER
THINGS WE CAN HELP YOU TO TAKE
A PROCESS. I'M I THINK THE
ANSWER IS YES AND I THINK YOU
YOU WERE GOING TO SEE OUR
COMPRESSION OF THOSE TIME LINES
I SPOKE A LITTLE EARLIER ABOUT
THE- PLANNING SLASH ACADEMIC
NATURE OF THOSE TIME LINES WE
HAD TO WE HAD TO MAKE
ASSUMPTIONS IN THE VERY
BEGINNING. FOR DURATIONS AND
THE LIKE AND- THEN WE HAD.
CONSTRAINTS THAT WE HAD A STAFF
CONSTRAINTS THAT WE HAD TO
CREATE THIS SEVENTEEN PROGRAM
LANDSCAPE. THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT AS WE'VE GOTTEN INTO
IT WITH EACH BOARDING BUREAU AS
MISTER POULIOT SUGGESTED THEY
WERE EXCITED TO DO IT THEY WERE
EXCITED TO BE ENGAGED AND THEIR
ACTIVITIES. XCELERATED IN AND
ACHIEVED EARLIER SUCCESSES THAN
THE STATED. DATES I WANT TO
SPEAK TO PHARMACY SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE THAT'S THAT. GUY THAT
THE DIED AT THE TAIL END OF
THAT SQUIGGLE PHARMACY I'VE
ENGAGED I BELIEVE I SPOKE TO
THIS BUT I'VE ENGAGED WELL A
LOT WITH THE LEADERSHIP. AT THE
FOUR BOARD OF PHARMACY NOW AND
THEY ARE AND- THEY ARE.
DEFINITELY LOOKING TO
ACCELERATE AND COMPRESS THAT
TIME FRAME LIKE I SAID THE
INITIAL FUNCTIONALITY AT THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY IS IN THE
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR TIME
FRAME BUT- I WOULD NOT BE
SURPRISED TO SEE THAT COMPRESS
EVEN MORE. IN THAT WE- ARE
READY ORGANIZATION. AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IS READY FOR
A CHANGE IS ONE THAT IS
SUCCESSFUL IT'S- A
PARTICIPATORY AN ACTIVE AND ALL
OF OUR PROGRAMS TO DATE ARE.
BECOMING THAT AND I THINK THAT
THAT LAST DOT IN THE SQUIGGLE
IS GOING TO ACCELERATE JUST
BASED ON THE- WORD OF MOUTH P.
R. THAT WE'RE GETTING FROM OUR
CURRENT BUSINESS MODERNIZATION.
PROGRAMS OTHER PROGRAMS ARE
HEARING OF THE- EAR BUSINESS
VALUE THAT THEY'RE ACHIEVING
FORGET I. T. FORGET ANYTHING
CHEATING CARE BUSINESS VALUE OF
LOOKING AT THEIR PROCESSES THAT
THEY MAY NOT HAVE HAD A CHANCE
TO LOOK AT IN A WHILE TO
IMPROVE THOSE. JUST THIS
TRIANGLES AND SQUARES ON A
PIECE OF PAPER HOW DO I PUT HOW
DO I. PUSH THIS PAPER THROUGH
OUR PROCESS DO I REALLY HAVE TO
HAVE IT HAD TEN STOP MAYBE I
COULD HAVE IT HAVE EIGHT STOCKS
ARE SIX STOPS INSTEAD. AND
THEY'RE REALLY RUDE THERE WERE
REALIZING A LOT OF PURE
BUSINESS VALUE. THAT. WORD OF
MOUTH IS GENERATING. ACTIVE
PART TIONS ORDER PHARMACY I'M
VERY CONFIDENT THAT THAT'S
GOING TO COMPRESS WITH
DISCUSSIONS IN THE VERY NEAR
FUTURE WE REPORT AGAIN. THOSE
DATES IN ANNUALLY IN OUR UP IN
OUR ANNUAL UPDATE SO YOU'LL BE
RECEIVING A REPORT IN AT THE
END OF DECEMBER. THAT. I'M
HOPING SHOWS THAT SOME SHOWS
COMPRESSED TIME LINES IN THAT
AREA ESPECIALLY THE LATEST ONE.
GREAT THANK YOU. GO AHEAD OF
SEX JUST I JUST WANTED TO POINT
OUT BECAUSE THIS FOR THE
RELEASE ONE BOARDS THERE THE
FIRST COHORT TO AND IT SAYS
THAT. IMPLEMENTATION DATE OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SIX ONE BUT
AS I WAS SAYING EARLIER IT WILL
HAVE ONLINE RENEWAL CAPABILITY
BEFORE THE END OF THIS YEAR.
AND SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE SOME
OF THAT CAPABILITY WELL BEFORE
YOU TO WE- ROLL THIS OUT A
COMPLETE PROJECT. AND I BELIEVE
ACUPUNCTURE IS LOOKING INTO
ADDING SOME C. E. TRACKING
FUNCTIONALITY AND THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO DO THAT. PRIOR TO
IMPLEMENTATION SO WE ARE
GAINING BENEFIT JUST THROUGH
THIS PROCESS. THANK YOU. GO
HADN'T AND OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO SHARE A
FEW WORDS RIGHT GREAT WELL THEN
WITHOUT I THINK WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND DIET AND WRAP UP THE
HEARING WHEN IT THANK OUR
PANELISTS AGAIN FOR JOINING US
I AM VERY ENCOURAGED I THINK
ABOUT A COUPLE THINGS HERE
FIRST YEAR THAT WE ARE LOOKING
FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO DELIVER IN
TRADE WINDS AN INTERN
FUNCTIONALITY I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S BAG. SECOND THAT WE ARE
THINKING ABOUT THIS I IN IN
TERMS OF SOMETHING THAT CAN
EVOLVE OVER TIME AND THAT THAT
WILL AYE BE ADAPTABLE AS FUTURE
TECHNOLOGIES AYE AYES FUTURE
TECHNOLOGIES EVOLVE BUT IT'S
ALSO GREAT TO HEAR YOU TOUT THE
COLLABORATION ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENT AND THEN BETWEEN
DEPARTMENTS. SO THAT'S ALL GOOD
NEWS I THINK. YOU I STILL. WE
DO HAVE A COUPLE OF CONCERNS IS
AS WE SHARED I THINK THAT. ARE
THE LACK OF A CLEAR BUDGET
GIVES ALL OF US PAUSE AND- AND-
AS THE PROJECTED TIMELINE I
THINK DOES CONTINUE TO GIVE ALL
OF US SOME PAUSE SO. I THINK MY
REQUESTS I'LL JUST REITERATE
WOULD BE IF WE CAN CAN TAKE A
LOOK AND IF THERE'S- A WAY TO
PUT TOGETHER EVEN IF IT'S A
HIGH LEVEL. BUDGET SAID THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE CAN UNDERSTAND
WHAT ACTUALLY WE'RE LOOKING HOW
WE THINK ABOUT. THIS IS
MODERNIZATION ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENT AND SECOND IF YOU
CONTINUE TO THINK ABOUT. WAYS
TO CONTINUE DELIVERED SOME OF
THESE INTERIM FUNCTIONAL WINS
THAT WOULD BE TRAFFIC. BUT THAT
THANK YOU AGAIN AND WE ARE
ADJOURNED